This is Jocko podcast number
79 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good Amy.
And it has been a little while since we
were able to hammer out some Q and a.
Sure.
Questions from the interwebs.
And so here we are number 79 let's
answer some questions from the interwebs.
What'd he got? Cool. Gill.
First question, John. Wait,
should we spend a bunch of time with a
bunch of fluff and talking about nonsense
or should we get to the questions?
Let's say we get to the question about
27 minutes worth of advertisements.
Let's get to the questions.
Rock and roll.
I am a vascular surgeon
training residents.
How do you apply decentralized command
when your team changes every one to three
month? Yeah, solid question.
And with something like that,
what we need to do is we need to get a
standard operating procedure in place
with clear documentation,
some kind of a qualification and approval
process and then a monitoring system
in place. Right. So this,
this the reason I can kind of,
the reason that's pretty easy transition
for me to make mentally is cause we
would have to do this kind of thing.
Sometimes in the seal teams when you get,
for instance,
you're overseas on deployment in a war
zone and you get some guys that show up
to work halfway through the deployment
or two months into deployment or three
weeks before deployment ends. You get some
guys that show up there, seals, right?
So they,
they,
they understand the fundamental concepts
but you haven't worked with them
specifically before. They haven't
worked with the platoon before.
They don't know the area of operations
that you're in specifically.
They don't know what kind of mission
specifically you're conducting and where
the Intel is coming from.
Big Basically,
I don't know anything other than the
fundamental knowledge of being a seal.
But as far as that particular job goes,
they don't know too much.
So what you have to do is you have
to run them through a bunch of
familiarization stuff very quickly about
the gun trucks and how your Humvees are
set up.
You've got to make sure they can get on
a 50 cal and a mark 48 and a mark 19 and
understand our crew served weapons and
how we operate them because our crew
serve weapons.
By the way.
A lot of times we most of the time
operating our cruiser of weapons alone,
so they got to make sure they
can do this Humvees right.
A lot of the older guys in the
seal teams before the war started,
they wouldn't know how
to operate a home fee,
so you had to make sure
they knew how to do that.
They had to understand the mission,
why we're doing the mission,
what was important about it,
what was the commander's intent?
They had to know the rules of
engagement because the military,
we'll take a guy that lands in country,
they'll give them like a 30 minute brief
to welcome to in country in 30 seconds
of it will be a rules of engagement brief
and they won't really understand it.
So you've got to make sure they understand
that you've got an when's the last
time they did med training?
Medical training. When's
the last time you did that?
Has it been like 12 years since they
put on a tourniquet? Okay, not good.
We got to get them familiarized on that.
How they going to stop the bleeding,
the different IED threats
that are out there.
Cause the ID threats change all the time.
What kind of trigger mechanisms are
being used and what kind of identifying
marks or for IED.
So there's all this stuff.
The list goes on and on and so you
have to develop some kind of a standard
operating procedure.
Hey, when a guy shows up,
this is what we need to do with them.
Boom, they need to go through this, this,
this, this, this, this little
checklist you put together.
And then if the person's a leader,
maybe you got to go and do a couple
left seat, right seat rides with them.
So does that mean, do other people use
that terminology? Left seat, right seat.
Not that I know.
Okay.
So if I was the platoon commander and
you are coming in to take over for me,
we would plan a mission together and I
would be in charge of the mission. Yeah.
So I'd be in the driver's seat
or like a pilot copilot. Yeah.
And you'd be in the next seat.
You'd be,
you'd be watching and you'd be in the
passenger seat and I would be running
everything. And then maybe we do that a
couple times and you're just watching me.
And then we switched seats.
You get the driver's seats.
But I'm still there watching
it and telling you to move
a little left to move a
little right. And then eventually you got
it. And then I'm going to leave, go home.
So maybe if the person's a leader,
you've got to do two or three
or four ops or whatever,
to get them a good turnover.
So that now when all of these situations,
or if you're,
if it's not a full on turnover cause
that you're going to walk away from,
but if it's just a, uh,
you've got some other groups,
small entity or people that are coming in,
you're not going to be able to give them
that full hundred percent decentralized
command,
right?
You're still gonna have to keep a little
bit more watch on them because you're
not going to build up the full level
of trust in one to three months.
That just not possible.
So there will be a little
bit of limitations,
but you can definitely,
you can definitely move
pretty far down the path.
And one other thing that's going to help,
I said document and that's really smart
to put together a document with very
clear roles and responsibilities and
expectations and then not just give them
the document and say, Hey,
read this letter. No, no.
You sit down and go over
every single thing with them.
So what you're trying to do is you're
trying to condense this timeline of
building trust into the
shortest possible time.
And one of the ways you
do that is by condensing
everything into a simple, clear,
concise format, written
format, go through,
talk it with them so they understand
it and getting to do it very clearly.
Like when I was in tasking at bruiser,
I didn't lay anything like that out for
the platoon commanders for life in the
Delta platoon commander. I didn't
say, here's the rules and there's,
I did that over a long for your time,
you know,
over a year workup now that
now we did a few months,
they kind of knew what the deal was.
But if I would have,
if that would've been my normal job and
I would have been getting a new platoon
commanders every three months,
every time they came in and be like,
are you a new between grantors?
We just hold up to the commander does,
this is the rules, rules, roles and
responsibilities. This is the, uh,
expectations that I have for you.
This is when you call me,
this is when you make a decision on your
own. Lay all that stuff perfectly clear.
And that way I could more quickly
develop a sense of decentralized command.
Now again, it's not going to
be full decentralized command.
You're not going to have to
just let somebody run with it.
They've only been together for three
months. And you know, I don't know.
I don't know what the timeline is too,
for a vascular surgeon to get total trust
in their subordinate vascular surgeons
or their subordinate team members.
But I'm sure it takes longer
than one to three months.
So how much can you condense the timeline?
What can you do to condense it?
Once you get a condensed,
as much as you can,
you're still going to have to do a
little bit more monitoring than you would
normally do,
but it is still going to be beneficial.
It's going to be beneficial for them
and it will be beneficial for you to
operate as much as you can in the
decentralized, uh, methodology.
So when you say condensed, the
timeline, that's for the procedure? No,
it's condensed. The timeline to build
trust. Oh, actually, so I want to,
decentralized command is about trust,
right? If I trust you and you trust me,
it goes up and down.
If I'm in charge and I trust you,
that means you're going to go out and
you know what to do and when you're out
there you know you trust that I am going
to cover for you and I'm going to trust
the decisions that you make.
So decentralized command is about
trust and who would have trust.
We have to have understanding and in
order to understand things we have to work
together.
So what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to condense the timeline that it takes us
to build trust and how do I do that?
I just am very direct and lay
things out in a very simple, clear,
concise format so that you can understand
it very quickly. That's my goal.
It makes sense.
Next question.
When and how is the right way to skip
the chain of command when you feel like
your direct superior is
a part of the problem?
Big One, big one. Because this is very,
very problematic and skipping the
chain of command is a last resort.
It is a last resort. Why is it
a last resort? Because when you,
when you skip the chain of command,
you're breaking the trust I just
talked about. You're breaking it.
The relationship that you've been
building, your damaging it, it's not good.
Sometimes it's an salvageable.
By the way.
Sometimes when you skip
the chain of command,
you will never be able to recover
from that. Now, of course,
if there's something that
the your immediate superior
is doing that's illegal or
immoral or unethical,
if that's the case,
then it's actually your duty
to go above them and the chain of command.
Now,
do you still first report it to them
and say, Hey, what you did is wrong.
We're not going to do that.
Yes,
you should tell them first unless
it's going to cause you to get in some
horrible situation. Now, this is an
interesting thing that I've thought about.
Let's say you and I are
working together. Sure. And,
and you're my boss and you,
let's say you're doing something that's
immoral, illegal, unethical, right?
And I watch you do it and, and I, and I
see you leaning towards it. I'm like, oh,
I think he's going to do something
that's illegal right here and I don't say
anything.
And then I watch you do it and then I
run up the chain of command report you in
Boston. You right. You gotta
be careful with that. And,
and I think when you work for someone
or when someone works for you,
you need to lay it right out of the
gate. Like, Hey, this is where I stand.
Like I'm not going to cover for you.
If you do some stupid illegal things.
You don't wait for them to do it
and then drop the hammer on them.
Maybe I'm being overly fair.
Maybe we should to be all out to
get people that are, you know,
doing something that they shouldn't
be doing part of the problem. Yeah.
I actually,
I believe that's my belief is when I,
when I meet you and I say, Hey, well,
what's going on? And you make a little
crack. You know, you make a little joke,
you know, you say, well, you know,
it's not like, it's not like the,
it's not like the, uh, customers
can really see that money. You know,
let's say you're going to skim
money, right? You got, yeah.
You make a little joke like that,
you know, you and you're in,
what you're doing is testing the waters
with me testing my ethical or moral.
So I'd be like, yeah, there's no way
they would ever know. And besides,
we pretty much work for
it anyways. Right, right.
You're going to see if we're going to
get that reaction with it. So, you know,
we just, you know, sometimes we
have good, got a little charge,
a little extra on that
install. Right. Maybe we're,
maybe we're some kind of installers
that house and usually, yeah. You know,
I usually throw a little upcharge on here
and they never know if that's type of
wall, whatever. Yeah. You throw
that test at me, it's my duty.
If I'm the type of person that's going
to report you for skimming money from the
customers, then I should tell you like,
hey man, that's not cool now. Yeah.
Now those customers that you know,
here's my view is those customers that
were out there trying to do this install
four,
they had to work hard for that money and
I don't want to be taken it from him.
Now you kind of know you better not be
doing that in front of me as opposed to
me smiling and going along with your joke.
And then three months later I report,
you know, a turnover report
to the boss man. Yeah.
So I don't think that's very
ethical. Evil. Yeah. It's
kind of like a mislead you.
It's a little bit of a backstabber.
Now are there cases of course where
somebody is doing something that's just
outrageously unethical and you
didn't know about it or something.
You pretty much know though you can tell
when people are doing shady things. So,
so I think that that is something,
okay, so let me, let me put it, let me,
let me close this thought or at
least make a point of this thought.
My point of this thought is it's the same
thing that happens a lot where people
don't like to have hard conversations.
So it's an easy conversation when you say,
you know what?
Those customers never know where their
money goes and it's only 12 bucks and
thing and it's no big deal.
The easiest thing for me to do is
to smile and say, Eh, yeah, right.
That's an easy, and, and, and that's
not that big of a deal, right?
It gets so much harder.
The further we go down that road,
it gets harder and harder
and harder because then you
start saying, hey, you know,
it's only, you know, we, we've been
scamming like 12 bucks. Guess what?
They never noticed this other charge
either. And I can get him for $62
and then all of a sudden
it's a harder conversation.
So have the hard conversation earlier,
it'll make it easier for you.
So
that being said,
now how do we escalate above you in
the chain of command? First of all,
my goal is to not escalate above
you and the chain of command.
My goal is to actually raise the situation
to you and bring it up to you and say,
Hey, echo, you know the way we've
been doing this job. You know,
I think we should do it a different way.
I think there's a better way to do it.
I think there's a better way to
treat the customer, whatever,
whatever the thing is, better
way to attack this target
or whatever the thing is.
And I'm going to have that
conversation with you like two, three,
four or five times to try and
get you to listen to me. Now,
if the conversation doesn't work,
I'm going to escalate it even further.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna actually do a little write up.
I'm gonna read a point paper.
I'm going to say Echo.
I was listening and thinking
about what we're doing,
how we're hitting this target or how
we're loading out our guys or whatever,
and I'm going to write you
a point paper and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna lay it out for him
to lay out what my plan is,
what the cost benefits are,
and make that very clear to you.
So that way I'm giving you every ample
opportunity to listen to what I'm saying.
Right. And I'm probably
even going to say, hey,
maybe we should run this by, you
know, the boss to see what they think.
Because if you just keep disagreeing
with me and I said, you know, can, can I,
do you mind if I bring it to the boss
and see what he thinks now what are you
going to say to that most? Most the
immediates are not going to be happy,
but I'm giving you a heads up
because I'm just trying to play open.
And it kind of doesn't, it kind of make
them reflect too, where it's like, Hey,
I'm going to, you know, bring somebody
there with, oh, what did he say? No,
don't bring that to the
boss. It's kind of like, ah,
it makes it real overt that they're
not doing correct. Yeah. So,
so yeah, you say, and you might get a
boss, you might get a boss goes, yeah,
bring it to him. He's going to say
the same thing I'm telling you.
And then you go home. Maybe I'm
wrong, I'm wrong about this procedure.
Or maybe I'm wrong about how we're
going to attack this target. But it is,
and also this is a hard
conversation to have.
It's a hard conversation to say someone,
man, can we just bring this to the boss,
sir? And, and, and again,
I'm not saying you say, Hey,
I'm going to bring this
to the boss and say, Hey,
would you mind if I got his opinion?
Would you mind if I see
what she said about this?
And that way we're,
we're not saying I'm going to the boss.
Go ahead and go over your head.
You can't stop me. No, that's
not what I'm talking about. So
there's that. The other thing
that you could, so that's,
that's sort of a direct approach
with your immediate boss,
which starts by the way, with an indirect
approach of being like, Hey Nico, you,
I was thinking about the way we're hitting
these targets. Wouldn't it be smart?
Maybe if we hit him from over here,
do you think that would work?
And now we're just opening up the
conversation. So we've done that.
I can also go indirect
with your boss. Right. So,
so your direct boss who's now to
up above me and the chain grant,
I can go in direct with him at
the Water Fountain, right? Yeah.
Hey. Oh yeah, thanks Paul.
See everything's going great.
Yeah. Doing a great job.
Yeah. Worker. Yeah, I'm on
echoes team. Yeah, yeah. No,
it's really good. It's good.
It's a tough mission. But you know, we're,
we're always exploring new ways to do it.
You know,
we're looking at some other ops.
I was thinking of the,
another way to hit those targets to kind
of like coming in from this direction.
Oh, that's all I did was just drop the
little plant a little seed, you know,
have that conversation come up and I'm
just going to, that's what I'm gonna do.
Plant the little seeds and try
and get them to maybe say, oh,
that sounds like a really good idea. What
Adecco think of that. I, I, you know,
actually I haven't talked to echo
about it in full detail, but uh,
I will not about,
hey man,
the boss asked me about this
and he was mentioning, you know,
I mentioned this other way of doing it
and he thought it might be good idea and
I just want to give you a heads
up in case he says anything. Uh,
I didn't really have a
chance, you know, whatever.
So we're just playing the game
a little bit. That's that line.
I just wanted to give you the heads up.
I feel like that's like real good
when someone says that it is, however,
it also gets a, it's also a way
of saying, Hey, I ratted you out.
I ratted you out. Depending on what
it's followed with. It's like, Hey,
I just want to give you a
heads up. The boss, you know,
asked me about this and I didn't know
how to respond so I said this and he had
to come and talk to you.
It's,
I just wanted to give you a
heads up that's different than I,
just to give you a heads up.
I talked to the boss earlier today.
I told him what your deal is, something
like that, that's not good for you.
So yeah, there's all kinds of shades of
gray there as well. And, and you know,
I worked for for a while I was
the admiral's aid and so I,
and I worked for a really great guy,
great admiral,
who I had a really good relationship with,
you know,
and if I needed something he
was going to give it to me.
And so when I was a task unit commander,
which is what,
which is what job I went to immediately
when I got done working for the admiral,
I literally had a direct line to the
admiral because I had his cell phone
number. I had his office number
and if I wanted to call him,
he wanted to talk to me
because we were friends.
But that doesn't mean that I went to him
and said, you know, did all kinds of,
you know, I didn't do that. No,
I never took advantage of that ad
at all and was always professional.
But there is this little story
where
as odd as this might sound,
we were getting ready to go
into the limit and we needed a,
uh,
what's called a large format color
printer and it prints out big pieces of
paper, large format. And
you need it because you need
to make battle maps. Yeah.
And you need a good one because
when you are on an operation,
every single guy in the platoon has a map.
So you could have,
you might need eight, 10, 12, 15, 30.
You might need 30 color laminated
maps to go out on a mission.
And for whatever reason, I think
we had one, it was kind of crappy.
And the boss, the admiral, you know,
I talked to him before I
was going on deployment.
I don't know if he called me
or I ran into him or whatever.
And he's the admiral in charge of
everything and he's just, you know,
getting a feel for what's going
on. And he says, um, you know,
hey you everything you need for diplomate.
Cause he knew I was leaving in a
couple of days or a couple of weeks,
couple of weeks and I said, yeah, you
know sir, we're, we're, we're good to go.
You know, right now, believe it or
not, I'm just waiting on a printer.
You've got to get one of those large
format printers for battle maps.
But other than that we're,
we're rocking and rolling.
And like that afternoon I got back
to my office and the commodore,
so now it's two bosses above my immediate
boss at the seal team and one guy
below the admiral, we don't have like
a message for me. He was like, hey.
And Luckily I was friends with him.
I guess you need a printer,
let me know what kind it is. Like thanks
for the heads up. And I was like, Hey,
sorry sir, I just saw him in the quickie
mart or whatever. But uh, but yeah,
you know,
you,
you gotta you gotta you don't want to
abuse that stuff at all and you got to got
to be smart about it and it's always
is, I'm telling you, it's always, it's,
it's not good to skip the chain
of command. It really isn't.
It's not going to generally is not going
to benefit you at generally going to
put you in a bad situation.
It's going to give you less
leverage with your immediate boss.
Cause if I went above
the chain command on you,
even with you get redirected by our boss,
you are pissed and you're gonna,
you're gonna sabotage. Yeah.
It's like a, it's really,
it's a version of going behind
someone's back. Oh for sure. It is.
And it almost even feels like even
if you tell them, it feels like,
oh you're going a my head going behind
my best. It's a really, it's a really,
it's a tough one. You got, you got to
use caution with that one. And also,
I'll tell you what else it is.
It's,
it's an easy, it's, it appears
to be the easy way out.
Like if you're not listening to me,
I'll call them.
She could go both the chain of
command instead of me influencing you,
explaining to you writing
point papers to you,
building a relationship with
you so that you trust me.
Instead of doing all those things
that take time and effort and tact,
I'm going to skip the chain of
command until your boss. So that's,
that's another negative about it. It's
a cop out. You shouldn't need to do it.
I can't like that printer
story I just told it like, Eh,
other than that,
me going above the chain of command
and that was almost a comical thing.
Like I said,
I was friends with the common or two
who always took great care of me and was
laughing when he left a message like,
oh, thanks for the heads up. You know,
he wasn't mad when he said that he was,
you know,
he was laughing because here I was
getting ready to deploy to Iraq and what I
want is a printer.
That's what we need,
which can tell you how dialed in we
were and how much great gear we, yeah.
Because the only thing that was left
that we need to as a printer, you know,
that's where I was at when I get old.
Everything we needed,
but I needed a printer. So you went above
his head and I get it for the printer.
But you got to, you know, other than that,
it's really hard for me to think of other
times in my naval career where I went
above someone in the chain of command.
It just didn't happen. You know,
I'm going to take the time to build a
relationship with my immediate boss and
they're going to do
what I want them to do.
They're going to get me
what I want him to give me.
They're going to support me the
way I needed to get supported.
That's what I'm going to do.
That's leading up the chain of command,
skipping the chain of command isn't really
leadership. Yeah. So try not to do it.
Kind of like when you're a kid and you're,
you got to deal with your
older brother or something,
but instead of dealing with them,
you going to tattle on him.
Something like that feel. Yeah. No,
it's the same. Same, a similar thing.
Not that my little brother tattled on me
ever in the flight. Yeah. Interesting.
How you, and it seems like this is
a common theme to how you were, uh,
like you want to try the most and the
best you can to deal with it yourself like
the most for sure. From the
beginning. I'll own it. I mean,
just like how you were saying how
like if you've got to fire someone,
you know where you want to get to the
point where deal with it in the beginning.
Yeah. Like you can't, like just let them
do the wrong thing. He'd be like, yeah,
that's cool. Let them do it for years
and then be like, you know what?
You're fired because of all these wrong
things and you didn't even bring it up.
And I think about this too, like on the
unethical things you, you might be, again,
I'm going to,
I'm going to walk a fine line here,
but you might not recognize,
you might not recognize that what you're
doing is unethical. He might be like,
Hey Jocko, you know, what I do is I just,
I always hit everyone with this little
extra $12 charge, you know, no big deal.
No one ever notices it. And uh, you know,
we're working hard and you might just,
hey man,
it gives you food for your kids and
you're working on a bunch of rich people's
houses so they can afford 12 bucks and
it's not that big of a deal to you.
And maybe somebody that you started
working for did the same thing.
And that's kind of just the
standard operating procedure.
Whereas if I was like,
man, you know what, that's not
good. You know, that's actually,
it might not seem like a big deal, but
you're taking money. You're, you know,
you know that puts money on your table,
gives you,
feed your kids and taking money
off their table. You know,
and whether they're rich or not,
money's money as I don't think,
I don't feel like we should be doing,
you know what I mean?
I can might awaken you and get your ethics
back on track and you might be a good
dude cause just cause someone was
skimming some money doesn't mean they're a
horrible person, right? It means
that they went down the wrong path.
It just because someone goes down the
wrong path doesn't mean they can come back
big doesn't mean they cannot come back to
the right path. Man, if I was, if I was,
you know, executed every time I
did something that was stupid or,
or bad or you know,
I shouldn't have done,
I would've died a thousand deaths by now.
Right?
We grow up and we learned these things.
We become better people but we only become
better people and we only learn these
things. If somebody teaches them to us
now we can learn the hard way, which is,
you know, all of a sudden someone
looks at you and goes, oh wait,
what's this charge for 12 bucks?
And then they follow up all your receipts
for the last five years you've been
working here.
And then they realize you've stolen money
from the company and stole money from
these customers and they're going to
prosecute you because stealing over x
amount of dollars is a felony.
You know what I mean?
So then you learn your lesson, but
that's not the lesson we want to learn.
So having those tough conversations
like you're talking about having them
upfront and whether it's urine we write,
whether it's counseling somebody,
whether it's dealing with, you know,
my boss who I want to tell like, hey,
I think there's a better way to do this.
Any of those. The earlier you do them,
the easier they are to have.
And the longer you wait to do them,
the harder they get. Yeah. So also too,
it's just an overall help. Like, I dunno,
it's hard to not draw the analogy, not
analogy, but the comparison between um,
like your boss in subordinate's
type situation and parenting kids,
you know, like for sure. Just like,
are you saying sometimes people don't
know necessarily that it's unethical or
they don't know it's that unethical or
something like that? That's, that's it.
I mean, in my situation with
kids, like they don't know,
essentially they don't know
better. You know, like, I dunno,
you take a permanent pen and you
draw all over the walls here,
four or five years old and
you're like, yeah, sure.
I've been drawing on paper
this whole time, so there's
no reason for me to think,
sure I should draw on the
walls, but there's really
nothing to tell me not to do.
So they do it and then they go get beat
or something like that or just yelled at
or something. Some, some
punishment, straight up
punishment instead of, you know,
okay, you didn't know that. You
have to know this. You know,
it's like that kind of stuff. How are
you going to tell the story? We were,
I was going through officer candidate
school and there's a manual and you're
going through officer candidate school.
I can't remember what it is,
but it's all the rules of officer
candidate school, everything you,
this is how uniform supposed to be. This
is the way your locker supposed to be.
These are the way you stay in
line at the Chow Hall. All the,
every single rule is in this book,
and I forget what it's called.
So you live by the code of this
book and it's very specific rules.
And there was a kid who was going through
officer candidate school with us and
he was from another country.
He had been raised in other country
and became an American citizen,
but he was from another country and
grew up in a really poor, you know,
a really poor kid.
So good for him.
I mean he had achieved incredible
amount finishing college,
going to officer candidate school.
It was awesome.
But he had some habits from growing up
in the third world that were a little bit
different for, you know, for Americans.
And one of the things that he would do
is he would urinate in the shower and,
and not just while he was taking a shower,
but when you come back from a class
or something, you know, you'd,
everyone has to go to the bathroom
at the same time. And so, you know,
guys would go in and they fill up the
urinals and then there's nowhere to piss.
So what are you going to do?
Well,
he would just go in the shower
and it's a big open shower.
You just go in there a piss right and
the drain. Like it was nothing. Toilet,
shower, toilet, shower, whatever
day. And one of the American kids,
and I'm calling the kids, these guys
were all, you know, actually we had,
some of them were new kids
fresh out of college. The kid,
the kid that was urinating in the shower
was fresh out of college and one of the
older guys who was like me,
it was a prior enlisted guy,
he came to me and he said,
hey man,
this kids urinating in the shower
like all the time. And I said,
I said, okay, well we know run
the water. And he's like, Brandon,
I got to get the exact exact,
you know,
my squad's in charge of
cleaning in the showers.
And so these are my guys on there on
the ground, the cleaning up his piss,
it ain't cool. And I was like,
all right, cool, I'll talk to him.
So I went and I said, hey
man, I said, hey, you know,
officer candidate, whatever,
can I, can I talk to you
for a second? He goes, yeah.
And he comes in my room and
I said, hey man, you, you,
um, you know, you're, you're,
you're pissing in the shower.
Just wait for a toilet.
And he looked at me like I was telling
him that he shouldn't breathe air, right?
He was like, well, why? And I
said, I said, well, no, because
you know, you're, you're,
you're pissing where everyone
walks around and he goes,
you have to do a water to drain
pipes in. He goes, and I said, no,
it's not, just, just don't do it.
He goes, it's not in the rule book.
This is what he said to me. And
I go, what do you mean? He goes,
and he named the manual.
He goes,
it doesn't say in there that you can't
piss in the shower. I was like, well,
it doesn't say you get piss on
my floor either order my bed,
but I don't want you to doing that.
But it was interesting.
My point is that his viewpoint was
like this was totally normal and he,
and he was a great kid and I just a hard
worker. But for him he was just like,
what are you talking about? Why wouldn't
I pissed in the shower? All the,
all the pictures are taken.
I'm going to go piss in the shower.
Well next question, let's
move on. I got work to do.
And so I had to explain to him, hey man,
listen, it's, it's a little different.
And people that are cleaning the showers
don't want to be down on their hands
and knees in your pis. So,
and he said, okay. And he,
he listened to me and,
but I could see that he listened to me,
but he didn't a hundred percent agree with
me. He was like, okay, that's fine. Yeah,
you kinda did that.
You know,
and it was one of those where I
tried to explain to them the why,
but it just needs,
it's like you're saying like he literally
didn't understand that that was not
acceptable from a hygienic point,
hygienic, hygienic, hygienic,
from a hygienic point, from a, you know,
a moral or our morale point
of the morale down there,
cleaning up. So yeah, that
was a, that was good times.
You never seen that Seinfeld, you watch
Seinfeld ever. I know what that is, right.
I know it's too negative. That's
what they talk. He gets caught.
One of the guys gets caught taking a
leak in the shower at the gym, you know,
and take a shower and then it's like,
you know, they catch you in the,
you're ostracized basically. I think
they even took his mat, I dunno.
But he was like, yeah, you believe this
there, whatever. You know, they're,
they're mad at me for, you know, pissing
in the shower at the gym. And he's like,
he's like, what, why are you confused
at, they're mad at you kind of thing.
And he's like,
it's all pipes.
We don't Google it.
You know,
he's trying to defend it and you can
kind of see where in a small, teeny,
tiny way, if you don't think
about it. Yeah. Like why not?
It's going down the drain. You're not
pissing on the, on the people. Hey,
I was deployed on a ship and
I was an officer as an ensign,
so I had just moved up from the,
from the troop virgin where I used
to be with the enlisted spine.
So we used to proudly call ourselves
and all of a sudden I was up in the,
in the officer area, in the A, what they
call those areas, officer country. She's,
they have little signs, officer country
and he, Oh, no enlisted allowed lead us,
totally lead us. So I'm in there
and I'm living with, uh, uh,
we actually had four other seals,
the seal officers in this room,
in one of the seal officers, there was
a sink in the room but no bathroom.
So you just had a sink, you
brush her teeth, shave, whatever.
But if you want to go the bathroom,
you to go down the hallway where
the showers and the pictures were.
And so one night I'm,
you know,
I'm like get stirred awake by some noise
and I see one of my fellow officers is
pissing in the sink right
in sync and you know,
I, I was like, hey man, what
are you doing? He's like,
I'm not walking all the way to then
down to the down to the bathroom.
And I was like, yeah,
actually, yes you are.
That's where I brushed my teeth homes
and he, and he was the same way.
He was kind of surprised
like what's wrong with you?
It's just pissed and it's the same pipes,
but right now do me a favor,
just walk on down there.
What if he urinated in the sink regularly,
but every single time when he was done,
he scrubbed the sync with like lights
and stuff, bro. It's all psychological.
I thought,
well it's not just psychological,
but that doesn't even make it worth it
now. You might as well walk down there.
I dig it. But like what if that
was just his thing? I mean,
well how would you feel about it? Don't
piss in my sink. Yeah, right. It's like a,
it's like a, it's like a, um, what do you
call like a customary almost for reasons.
Of course.
The reason is don't piss it.
Actually in college we played football
and we did it like a nice facility too at
Uah. But the showers were like,
guys would do it all the time and,
but the showers were shaped different
where like let's say you're facing the
shower,
right?
Or you're facing the wall at the bottom
of the wall was like a gutter trench.
Yeah. So it went down. So if you did
and one guy's would, it would go to Aa.
You weren't ever standing in it, you
know? So if you're standing in it,
that's like obvious, you know,
but, but guys would do it.
And when I first saw it I was like,
Dang, he just openly doing it.
Like one of this,
I actually mentioned this,
maybe it's where I'm not gonna
mention cause it fits in the shower,
but he's like talking to me
while he's pissing in the shower.
Almost like it was a straight up toilet.
It was like I said and he's like, yeah,
I'll talk to me. And I'm like,
alright. That's how, so again,
it's more like the ethics of the,
like the,
the culture almost is what it seemed like.
Yeah.
What it seems like to me is don't
piss in my sink. I agree. Oh yeah.
The sink is different. Different
ballgame. Yeah. Shower. Okay.
Understood. Right. Like you said,
it goes down the drain and it's,
there's water flowing all over it.
Yeah.
You're washing it off anyway off the slope
coming over it. But uh, you know what,
I got a good idea. Just as a
general overall rule, pissing the I,
we better do that one.
Yeah.
The same way and probably not going
to brush your teeth in the toilet.
That's what the thing is now.
If you want to pay,
if you want to brush your teeth in the
toilet, have at it. I won't be mad at you.
I'll be mad at you. I don't know if I can
hang out with you as much or whatever,
but yeah, I understand.
It makes sense. Talking,
talking toilets from talking about
skipping the chain of command. Oh yeah,
that's right. Cause the guide ocs
officer candidate school. Yeah.
You got us into the shower.
He had to let them know up.
You've got to have the hard conversations.
I wonder whatever happened to him.
He was a hard work where we see from
somewhere like Vietnam
or Laos or something.
MMM.
Maybe Thailand, some Asian, Asian
countries. Southeast Asian country.
Yeah. Hard worker and smart.
Yeah. I would think, yeah.
My opinion about taking a
leak in the shower is you
shouldn't do it. But if like,
like this guy who's like,
oh that's normal.
That doesn't totally surprise me though.
Yeah. No, it doesn't surprise me,
but it makes sense that guys didn't
like it though. For sure. Next question.
And, and, and don't skip the chain of
command if you can avoid it by yeah,
don't do that either. Yeah. Anything
going behind someone's back.
It just, it just like how you say it,
it's like sometimes you can't repair that.
It's harder to repair,
harder to repair.
Hello.
How do you rank your
longevity in your priorities?
Longevity. This is talking about
staying alive for as long as possible.
And of course, I mean I want
to live, oh like how do I,
how do I personally,
that's the way it was court.
The question is actually directed at me.
Jocko Willink. Question for the podcast.
How do you rank your
longevity and your priorities?
Longevity being how long are you
going to live for? And for me,
I mean obviously the longevity
has some level of importance.
I do want to live for a
little while longer, but, and,
and I think that generally my lifestyle
and my focus on health and fitness in a
broad way align with
living for a little longer.
So, you know, working out
and all that stuff is good.
But there's also an extreme,
and I don't know if you know this,
I don't know how much you know about
this or if you've ever read about it,
but there's an extreme side of
longevity of trying, if you,
if your goal in life was to
live as long as possible,
there's an extreme version of that. Do
you know about this? I Dunno how so? Well,
one of the biggest things is you,
you do
a calorie restriction from
massive calorie restriction.
You're talking like massive calorie
restriction and that's one of them.
You and,
and believe it or not,
you do extremely low levels
of physical activity. Yeah.
Right? You, you basically, if your
goal was to live as long as possible,
you would want to live basically in a
bubble and do nothing but eat very little
and just lay there. Hmm. Um,
no Jujitsu, didn't know surfing,
no lifting, heavy weights,
none of that stuff.
Now when you're in that mode of longevity,
pure longevity, you are not prepared
for anything in the actual world, right?
Because your,
your heart can only beat so many
times and if the less you use it,
the longer it's going to be lasting.
But,
and I'm sure I have that not quite right,
but the problem is if you're not in
good shape, when you get surprised,
your heart can't handle it.
That's the kind of people that have heart
attacks because the heart can't handle
all this madness when it comes.
So I'm not going there.
It's not worth it for me too.
For me to live my whole
life as a sedentary person,
half starved and completely unprepared
for anything to happen to me outside of
my bubble is not happening. I'm
not going to live that way. Um,
so where does it rank in my priorities?
I think it's it.
Sure it's an important thing,
but I think my general lifestyle aligns
with enough that I don't think about it
as much.
And I think overall living life is
more important to me than just living.
Yeah.
So it makes got to live life.
What if magic,
like a magic wizard guy says,
I'm the gatekeeper of your whole life,
whatever your life and death situation,
he's a grim reaper. That's
what it was. And he said,
I know when you're gonna die,
you know you can't help it. This,
I just know the future,
whatever.
I will give you 20 extra years.
Right now you're,
you know, 40 something years old, the day
you're going to die, whatever that is.
I can't tell you that.
Maybe 90 maybe 80 whatever,
but I'll give you 20 more
years of fully functional life.
But you got to stop doing Jujitsu right
now. You can never do that ever again.
I'd probably choke him out.
Next question.
Otherwise you'd be just as functional.
You can laugh, you can surf, you can,
you know, you can get after it in, in
every other way. Just know Jujitsu.
No martial arts in any way.
You know what?
I would double leg him
and then I would pass his guard and
then I would choke him. Yeah, yeah,
makes sense. And I'd take his
sickle. Yeah. And I free the world.
Well,
a Jiu Jitsu life is
not life.
That's what you're saying.
I think the minute you start restraining
yourself from doing things that you
want to do, you would need to take serious
considerations in what you're doing.
Yeah.
I also think that hypothetical questions
like that are completely ridiculous.
No, they're not. They're
mental exercise. So my,
that's why then in that case I will stay
with my first answer. Yeah, I agree.
If the grim reaper came to me and made
me an offer, I would double leg him.
I would take him down and I would joke,
I'm out. There you go. I might kill him.
Yeah, I might kill Beth.
Yeah, there you go. See Boom.
And you can't do that without you just
do so as far as the double leg and
choking someone up. So back to your, um,
how do you say how the longevity thing,
it didn't know about that actually.
Yeah.
And it,
and it makes sense cause that's a lot
of things like if you want to be the
safest you possibly can in
life, right. The same thing.
You can just get to live in a bubble
with no threats of any disease,
sterilized bubble, no murders,
no car accidents, no nothing,
never drive, never do anything. The
same thing. Well, you'll be so safe,
you'll be the safest person
in the world. Really. Yeah.
But as far as quote unquote living life,
you know, you go one day out in the,
in the wild, all you're dead. Same thing.
Like if you restrict all your calories,
no hard physical activity,
no son, you know, all this stuff.
The moment you go to everyday life,
which is physical in some is less
waste than before, but still physical.
There's Sun, there's days when you go
out there all year. That's right son.
All or nothing. Yeah. Take
Vitamin D pills. The uh,
the other thing is with calorie
restriction is I think, and you know,
I'm reading about this
stuff all the time and,
but you can get a lot of those benefits
by doing some intermittent fast for sure.
Yeah. And you will feel good on the
intermittent fasting. Yeah. 24, 48,
72 hours.
That's the most I've done is you know,
and maybe I'll do some more in the future.
Tim Ferriss did like seven days.
Okay. I want you to actually,
you know, I dunno man.
Yeah, yeah. But in c and that's it.
That almost goes into a whole, honestly,
when I did 72 hours the last
time I did it the same thing.
I've done it a couple of times
now. Every time I feel fine. Yeah.
I don't feel any of this stuff that
people talk about. Yeah. Well yeah.
So I mean it's, this is almost even,
I feel hungry for a little while,
but I do, I wasn't like, Oh God. Right.
Who wasn't going to die? No, you were.
No, but you're talking about
a whole different thing.
If people are going to say,
people are gonna ask on the interwebs
to talk more about intermittent fasting.
No, don't ask me. There's like
actual research out there.
Go and Google it. Look up and harassed
fasting and read about it. Don't ask me,
I'm the wrong person to ask. You.
Ask Smart People. Yeah. And again,
that intermittent fast,
like if you're talking about
like did like 10,000 questions
on Twitter because it's true,
don't ask me Google it and look at
these really good research paper.
There's all kinds of stuff
coming out about it right now.
Now what's weird about the Internet
and science in general is in,
you know, there's a one
article that says it's great,
you can find two more articles
that say it's horrible.
You can find three more articles.
So you can always count on
everything. Yeah. I mean,
although the have to split hairs,
but that's not necessarily
about science in general.
It's more about a specific person's
viewpoint based on what they've k yeah,
for sure. For sure. Um, and especially
with diet and health, it's so,
it's so ambiguous and so
adaptable and stuff like that. So,
but if you're talking about
fasting, that's, that's,
you're talking about something different.
Like people fast for a specific reason
or even that kind of a general reason,
but it's like fascinating alone isn't
going to make you achieve whatever it is
you're doing. You know, it's a complete,
just like lifting, like with lifting,
you need nutrition,
you need rest,
you need all this stuff for a specific
results and then there's all kinds of
different lifting, you know? So
you can't just be like, oh yeah,
I want bigger muscles so I'm just
gonna lift. That's it. No nutrition,
I'm not going to eat at all or no rest,
I'm not going to rest at all.
So the point there is when you go try
and live as long as you possibly can,
it's like you have to like that has to
be the objective just to live everything
else is, everything else is
out the window. So you, yeah,
I don't, I agree with you. I don't
think that that's living necessarily.
I don't think there's too many people
that are just on the full on lung
longevity Gig. But there are
some, yeah, I know, I know one,
I'm not going to mention his name.
Check I guess would be your little secret.
Next question.
Similar question. Yeah.
Jocko, prioritize and execute.
Is it wrong to sacrifice health in short
term to accomplish work objectives and
how would you make up
the time lost? So yeah, absolutely.
Sometimes you have to sacrifice
workouts for health and health for work
objectives.
There's no doubt that's the life
and work in many respects his life.
And that's kind of another topic.
But try and love what you're doing,
trying to enjoy your job if you don't,
because if you enjoy
your job then work is,
life is an okay thing. If you hate
your job, then work is, life is not a,
is not a good situation to be in.
So try and get into things and do
something that you enjoy doing and if you
don't enjoy it, you know, find
some kind of an exit strategy.
But that's another topic.
Going back to this topic,
is it okay or is it wrong to sacrifice
your health and the short term to
accomplish long term
work objectives and yeah,
even in the seal teams we did
that all kinds of times a lot.
Whether it was in training or for mission,
where our priority or our mission or our
training takes priority over workouts
and over eating healthy
and over everything.
So there's times where a hundred percent
focused on some kind of mission and
that's what you're going to, that's
what you're going to do and that's okay.
That's what we did in the seal teams
and that's what everyone does and it's,
and when you get done with that,
how do you make up for lost time?
You do some hard workouts and
maybe you go eat super clean,
are you fast for a little
while or whatever it is
that gets you back on track,
you just get yourself back on track. What
you have to watch out for is a pattern,
a long term pattern where work takes
precedent over health for multiple weeks,
right? Multiple weeks and
months, right? If it's,
if you're talking about months,
we're in a bad situation. Like,
if you go week two weeks where
you just were crazy and work,
it was crazy and you, you know, you know,
your health took a little to went down
a couple notches on the priority and a
couple of weeks goes by and
you cook food with, I'm God,
I'm God through that and the, the, the
hard seasons over or the whatever the,
you know, like, you know,
people in the finance world and taxis and
they're just busting their ass for two,
three, four straight weeks. It's really
hard. It's understandable. And you know,
uh, retail people around Christmas
time, there were, you know,
everyone's got their
little cyclical things,
real estate people in the springtime
and the summer starts rolling around in
their work. It's, it's, they're
cyclical things and that's cool.
You work hard for two, three weeks
where you just have to get after it.
But when that starts turning into months
in and multiple weeks and then months
and then six months of your
health is taking the backseat,
we have an issue. Now, that being said,
there are not too many jobs that consume
23 and a half hours a day of your time.
They're just not that many jobs that do
that now and what you might be facing
here as you might be blaming
your job for you being lazy,
that that can be happening.
That's a strong possibility actually,
because you can make time for
a 20 minute workout, right?
20 minute workout, right? 20
minute work. I'd like that.
If you get 20 minutes, you get in there,
shake it out a little bit and you do.
But you know, couple hundred
burpees go as hard as you can.
You just got to workout that took
you 10 1520 minutes. Right? Well,
longer than that for me, but yeah. You
see what I'm saying though? I do. Yes.
Fully you d and then if you can do that
for you, sprint, if you do 10 sprints,
right, it doesn't take you much time.
You do go, go knock out three, four,
five sets of pullups.
Go knock out a couple of hundred pullups.
How long does that take? It
doesn't take that long. Right?
Take you 15 minutes,
you're done.
So then maybe at night
you just roll up there,
you grab your Kettlebell and
you knock out some swings.
It takes you seven minutes.
We're not talking about a bunch of times.
So are we being lazy cause we're
not carving out 1520 minutes,
half an hour.
You know a lot of people ask me about
what the workouts I do when I'm on the
road. A lot of times when I'm
on the road, I fly into a city.
I'd get there at 11 o'clock
at night the next time,
next day I'm working with a company at
eight o'clock in the morning and so my
schedule is tight. Why am I in
the hotel room? The hotel room,
Jim's sucks for one thing and I'm
going to bang something out quickly.
You know it's not going
to be an hour workout. No,
it's going to be like
20 minutes sometimes.
Now sometimes if I have
a little extra time,
maybe I'm not meeting with
the company until lunch. Cool.
I'm going to have a nice long
workout of course, but if it's,
I'm due to meet with the CEO for breakfast
at seven o'clock it's going to be a
quick hardcore 12 minute
workout and that's cool.
So you got to carve that out.
And so you know,
make sure that it's the job that's doing
this to you and not you that's doing
this to you.
Yeah.
So if it is your job,
truly,
truly your job is the thing that's making
you unhealthy, then you got to fix it.
Now what you have going for you is that
companies want you to be healthy, right?
Companies understand the benefit
of having healthy employees,
not just from a productivity standpoint,
but from like an insurance viewpoint.
We, if we got to, you know,
we've got a health coverage for our
employees and all of our employees are our
sick and lame and lazy and we're having
to pay their medical bills and they
can't work. It's problematic. So what
you do is you step up and you say, Hey,
you know what? We don't have a health
and wellness program. I want to run it.
We need a little gym. Oh yeah,
it's going to cost money. Yes,
it's going to cost money, but I'm going
to save you money and productivity.
I'm gonna Save you money and insurance.
I'm going to write a point paper on that.
I'm gonna win that one all day long.
We're going to,
we're going to put a gym in the
lounge and we're going to put,
we're going to put some mats in the
donut room. You know what I'm saying?
So we're going to, we're going to do it
when I think linkedin has a Jujitsu room.
You mean like the headquarter?
I think I saw a picture of they have
a Jujitsu Room. Good idea. Yeah.
You didn't even have to pay me to work
there. So you've got Jujitsu room boy.
Free memory. Yeah. So you
get so, so go, you know,
step up your company. I can
about guarantee your company
wants you to be healthy.
So step up,
maybe take a leadership role in forming
the health and wellness program for your
company. Get flooding. My,
uh, my brother's company.
You know it up. He, uh, he,
they don't have then on Mattson
everything in the office but yet yet yet,
but are working. Um, it's funny though,
he'll, he'll like, he'll do this,
he'll encourage people to go to Jujitsu,
you know,
to the point where they
have rash guards even. Yeah.
We have a pretty good representation
from frag at the gym. Yeah.
You don't, I call everyone from
frag mom that trains, you know,
and I had nicknamed them, well all of
them frack mob. Hey removed from frag mob.
That's America. That's their actual name
Jim Anymore? No, your name is frank mob.
Yeah.
But that's good because it becomes this
culture that kind of catches on where,
and this is just,
you're just so,
it can be kind of anything crossfit
or even spin, I dunno, whatever.
But you is kind of good cause it's one
of those ones that you can kind of come
and talk about it and you know,
choked you out or you
choked me out kind of thing.
You can choke your boss if he's there,
you know, it's like that kind of stuff.
It's really fun. Your boss. And they even
have like rat, like I said, rash guards,
the rash guards. Like if you work for
fragment, it'll say staff on the back.
It'll have, uh, like, you know,
they do like AI and development,
stuff like that. So the,
the staff one will be, um, what does
it have on the sleeves? Like digital,
digital circuitry. Yeah. And then the
other one says, we'll say security.
That's like,
you know,
friends of friends or the friction
between the hardware and the software rash
guard. That's what I mean. That's
exactly what it is. So the soft,
the guys who actually worked
for a fragment have the
software rash guards that
has like circuitry and the design and then
the, the, you know, the hardware. Oh no,
sorry. This software is
zeros and ones. Yes, exactly.
And the security guys who were,
anyway, nonetheless, that's kind of,
that's like a good cause that's not really
an official program in fragment or in
a company. It's just, it's kind of the
influential element of the culture.
You know where it's like, and you know
my brother, he, he, he, he pushed that,
you know, kind of overtly I
guess, but it's more, it was like,
you guys have to do this. It's kind
of like, hey, you should come down.
I'll give you a rash guard and okay,
cool. And guys, and it was funny.
There's a time, there's a bunch of
fragmented people in there just going.
Interesting. But yeah, that
helps. That does help for sure.
Now the thing is if none of that works,
if you,
if your company's just dragging you down
and you've checked and double checked
and triple checked your own discipline
or lack of discipline and you realize
that it's the work that is bringing
down your health, in that case,
you got to follow the procedure.
You've got to find an exit strategy,
create an exit strategy, save
up your money, line things up,
get the ducks in a row in the next queue
because your health is going to be more
important than everything else.
Yeah. Then everything else,
all that money you could possibly make.
If you've got to sacrifice
a year and a half,
two years and you're going to grind it
out like an investment banker that shows
up on Wall Street,
he's going to grind for two years
and their health is going to suffer,
but they've got a goal at the end of that.
Hey understood you.
Sometimes you've got to do, but you got to
at the end of that two, three years, he,
if you,
and if you're not there and you're not
where you want to be and you're starting
to decline in health,
they're going to get some stuff that
you won't be able to recover from.
So make your,
make your decision.
Then you come up with an exit strategy
and move on. Do something else. Yeah,
and health,
health and even like fitness is,
is this thing,
it's called systemic
versus direct, you know,
as far as being beneficial.
So exercise is like one of the few things
in your little hierarchy of needs or
whatever that affects
everything else. Like if you,
if you're an unhealthy person
versus a healthy person,
a healthy person will be
better at everything else.
He'll be better at making money.
He'll be better at all relationships.
He'll be better off.
Obviously health wise in and of itself.
I mean obviously if you've got some guy
that's brilliant and really out of shape
versus a guy that's an
idiot who's in great shape,
the brilliant person's probably going
to make more money and do better in the
long run.
I mean,
I were talking and you have to put them
on a level and intellectual playing for,
yeah, you're talking about
the same person. Yeah.
Then for sure for sure for your
person and wasn't going to win,
but so and compare that to the direct
thing like, well, people would be like,
hey mate, making money's important. So
it's more important than the health.
But his thing,
making money doesn't improve your health.
Making money doesn't necessarily improve
friendship or romantic relationships
necessarily. In fact, a lot of times
it damages them. A lot of the times.
Health doesn't damage anything.
It improves everything.
There's not anything that I can think
of anyway that health makes worse.
Yeah. Or being more fit and makes
worse. Get healthy. Stay healthy. Yeah.
Stay on the program. You know what? Um,
and it's one of those things to men like
working out when you're on the road,
that's a big one,
right?
It's hard to like get a solid workout
on the road because you're busy or
whatever. But there's, this is going to
sound crazy but when you think about it,
it's not, not crazy but sound
kind of unrealistic where, okay,
so this is what I've been doing recently
when we went to New York for the muster
and like all these other,
some before I go,
I'll research Jujitsu gyms and
fitness gyms where it can work out.
Cause like you said,
the hotel gym is like,
if you don't have anything else in yet
but you still have time, okay good.
But our research, where are the
gyms and prepare like, okay,
how long is it going to take me to get
their workout, get back all this stuff.
And then you fit it in your
schedule and you know the thing.
If you don't want to fit in your schedule,
then don't work out.
Then if been health is not for you then,
but if you're like, oh, you're asking,
you know this kind of question where
you know is it wrong to sacrifice health
and all this stuff,
that means you're concerned about health.
Then be concerned about health.
You can fit it in there.
Surprised what you can fit in.
Just like you don't have to get that good
of a workout but you're fitting it in.
But here's the thing,
you can fit in a good workout.
You just got to make room for that and
you've got a psychological when too,
like I,
if I'm going to speak
somewhere at a minimum,
I'll do a couple a hundred burpees before
I go before I went to wake up because
that just gets the blood flow and
you're ready to rock and roll.
But at the muster I,
there was no break in the program.
I went to 24 hour fitness.
I've rolled a hard one and hands those
and then we rolled out at the muster,
which wasn't hard necessarily,
but there's a lot of roles
in there and so man it was,
there was no break in the program,
but the point is because I knew
that that was the I, I made time.
Exactly right.
It
was important and I don't want to say
it's important like it's the number one
priority. I'm saying it's part
of the, the whole what I'm doing.
If it's not part of what you're
doing and then don't be healthy,
then don't make it part of what you're
doing. I vote against you on that one.
I say make time. Be Healthy. Yeah,
I think so too. That's my opinion.
But I'm saying you help
people like I don't have time.
My job is so whatever. Hey, if
you straight up don't have time,
then you don't have time. Help is up
for you. You chose everything else.
When we're healthy and that's up to you
wasn't going to go ahead and go in on a
limb here that most people you
can make time. That's the point.
That's my weak point half
hour earlier because you know,
you know when you really don't have time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like one time,
I don't know, two or three months
ago we were, we came in and we,
we skipped Jujitsu to record
the podcast and I was like, man,
we skipped Jujitsu to record. The primary
is good. We had no choice. It was like,
we didn't do that.
We weren't going to get on a flight in
the afternoon and we just had to do it.
And so, yeah. Okay. Actually
that those things happen.
Yeah. So consider that. Right.
So it's either skipped,
you'd get to one day and get the podcast
out or don't do it. We could either,
we could have chosen, trained Jujitsu,
don't do the podcast. But at that point,
given all the circumstances,
the podcast at one day,
it's keeping you to just do a one day.
It's more important for that one day
because it's not like we're giving up
Jujitsu completely for this,
but it's not that are actually holding
the line with a podcast. Exactly. Right.
And that was important that day because
we were kind of faced with that thing.
What do you give up? So what, that's
the question. What do you give up?
Do you give up watching
a movie and room service?
Do you give that up? Give that US
give that up. Like I said, hey,
if you don't have to ask,
we don't want to go to hotels.
I don't even turn on the TV.
Yeah you cause I don't have TV at home.
And so I don't know,
a year or two ago I went to some hotel
and I've turned on the TV and next thing
I know,
you know an hour and a half went by and
I was watching some movie from 1986 this
is going, you've gotta be kidding me. Turn
it off. And you know what I always do?
I hang my chalk bag on the TV. That's
my, as my standard operating procedure,
I hang my child. Cause you know how
they're all the thin TVs when you travel?
When I travel. So you bring
your chocolates? Yes. Chalk bag.
I bring sweat bands for my wrists
because I sweat, I bring a chalk bag,
I bring my little notebook,
I brings good on mobility wad
ball to do some mobility work.
And I bring some one inch tubular
nylon that I used to stretch.
Oh that's right.
You're a good team.
Like when we went to the
muster I brought rings with me
cause I knew I was gonna
be on a tight timeline.
I knew I was going to have to get some
workouts done and I traveled a little bit
heavier. Yeah. Cause I
normally travel really light.
But I had an extra bag so then
no rings. Amen. No factor.
You were there for a while too.
A couple of weeks I was in Austria and
then came back to New York and then from
New York to Texas. So there
was a road trip. Yeah. Dang.
See and you made it happen and you're
busier than the normal person in my
opinion. Kind of busy in
from, yeah. But again man,
I think you know how that
old saying I think, I dunno,
you might've said it might have been
Henry. I don't know where I saw it,
but it's like there is no free time
or spare time or you know, worked at,
there's just time. You know,
it's, it's one of those Rollins,
so it's like time. So there's no
spare time. There's no free time.
There's just like this time. Yeah.
So you better just get on it.
So unless you're like Peter,
a tear member when he was talking about
what Peter Theo was talking about,
like there is no time.
You're just working the whole time.
Like you can't even sleep
when he's at med school.
So if you're in that situation,
the, then that makes sense.
You're not going to be like,
Hey,
I'm not doing this part of my
med medical program here though.
You can put that on the side of the road
to a park to fall asleep for an hour
because you hadn't slept the nine days.
Yeah. So there are exceptions for sure.
But again, like if you're doing
room service or you're, you know,
you're watching the game or you're
stopping at the bar or doing anything,
I'm not even saying
necessarily destructive things.
I'm just saying things that
aren't conducive to your
quote unquote work that's
keeping you so busy or
whatever that are essential.
If you're doing these other things,
then there's where you can make time.
How can one ever have time if
you don't take time? I like it.
Next question.
My wife and kids are quick to anger.
Sometimes it's explosive like
the Moab mother of all bombs.
Other times it's a slow
grinding war of attrition.
Being a student of your podcast,
I've learned the worst strategy is to
directly attack there to fight emotional
position.
It seems like this is a good opportunity
to employ the flanking maneuver.
How do I effectively flank their
anger without appearing weak?
Okay. First of all, thank yourself
cause at a period week thing,
that's pretty much in your head.
Really it is.
It's legitimately in your head and
that's the first thing you need to do.
That's your ego talking when you
don't want to, when you don't want to,
when they hit you with
something that they're angry at,
the thing that's hitting back his ego,
that's what's hitting back.
So first thing you got to do is,
okay,
I'm going to check my ego right now
because I'm going to win the long war.
In fact,
you have to be careful when you stay calm,
when everyone else is angry.
You have to actually be careful not
to come across as aloof or arrogant.
Yeah, yeah. Like when people are getting
mad, okay, here. Okay. For instance,
if your wife is super mad about something
and you show no emotions and you don't
get mad at all, they get matter. So that's
right. You don't even care about this,
you know, so, no, no. So you've got to,
you've got to give a little bit, you know,
I'm not saying it a little bit of a,
I get it.
Right. But then we're trying to do is
absorb. Oh, they want to get mad, cool.
Absorb. Take the screaming.
Give the head nod of
understanding in a Ma only
marginally emotional way.
That pretty much communicates that.
I understand. You're mad at him.
I'm listening and I hear
you. You know, I get it.
And let them get it out of their system.
This, let them get it. Honor system.
Then let them calm down.
And then after you've given them the time
to kind of calm down and settle down,
and I mean it's a longer than you think.
It's,
it's longer than you think. Let them
let, let, when you think they're calm,
wait an extra 45 minutes if not two hours,
probably two hours,
cause they're not called to be safe. They
just stopped screaming right there. So,
and then what you do is, and then which
dudes, you're kind of take it on yourself.
You're going to own it, right?
And you say something like, Hey,
you know that thing that made you mad?
I want to make sure it doesn't happen
again. Right. You know what can,
what can I do better to make sure that
you don't get mad about that, right.
You take,
you take ownership of that.
What do I need to adjust
and what exactly is it that,
that I did that frustrated.
What is it that frustrated you?
What can I do to stop it? Maybe it wasn't
me. Maybe you're mad at the printer,
but you know, how can we fix that?
Because I don't want you to do it.
And then you know,
so you have the,
that kind of conversation and you know,
you're going to slide something tactfully
and their tactfully, because again,
you're still dealing with like,
you know,
possible flare up scenarios
happening. So you know, but,
but you say something like that,
you know,
we both know that nobody benefits
when people lose their temper. Right?
I mean we gotta be
careful, you know, no one,
it doesn't do us any good when people lose
their temper, we, everyone knows that.
Right?
So you slide those things in there.
You're given that kind of like a little
mini lecture indirectly about what's
happening. And then when you
have other conversations,
now we're in just a normal day to day
thing. You drop things about temper,
you know, you talk about
tempurpedic, well, you know,
it's a weakness and it's no one makes
good decisions when they have them then
those are temporary,
everything.
And so some of the dumbest things I've
ever done was when I logged, you know,
everyone knows that.
But you know,
you say you start sliding those things
in there that it's bad for your decision
making. It's bad for relationships, it's
bad for your health, it's bad for life.
And again,
you're not directly saying these things.
You're subliminally saying even,
you know it's man.
I remember one time I lost some little
dumbest things I ever did when I lost my
temper and I kicked the wall and I
broke my toe and I bought a home,
a wall and the landlord came.
I, that's when I s man, I
hate when I lose my temper.
And you start getting them in the,
even thinking about it over time,
and this is the thing,
it's a long war and there's going
to be relapses along the way,
but you got to just hold the line,
keep it steady,
absorb and then flank gently to get them
to salt start self recognizing where
they're at and what their
temperature does to him. [inaudible]
tempers crazy. Yeah. You see
people lose their temper. It's,
it's a total loss of control. Yeah. It's
a total loss of control and it's does,
it doesn't do anybody any good.
And when you see someone that really
loses their temper, you're like,
what is wrong? Come on. Yeah.
And when I was a kid and I used to
lose my temper and at some point I just
realized,
I forget what it was.
I forget what made me think there
was something my dad said to me,
there's something about, you know,
something along those lines of like,
you lose your temper. It's like a
little baby. Oh, loss of control. Okay.
So you, you, when you realized it, that's
because of something my dad said to me.
Something along the lines of light,
you know,
I think he was referring
to an athlete or something,
someone that just had no emotions
and how that was impressive. Yeah.
And I was like, hmm, that is
impressive. Massive control over that.
Nothing is going to make me mad. It
doesn't matter what's going on around me.
Yeah. Yeah. It is like a baby,
you know? Like I said, it'd
be, you know, like babies,
they cry and they whatever,
cause they don't know how to talk.
So if they knew how to talk and control
everything, they just be like, hey,
I'm cold. Or Hey, I'm hungry,
but they don't know how to talk.
So why do adults go crazy and cry?
Because their babies,
cause they don't know how to talk if they,
if they die for every little thing,
they're babies. Yeah. They don't know how
to talk. I said actually you know what,
under any,
depends.
It depends how much controlling and
all these other little variables.
But it's like the front part of your
brain. That's the decision making.
Like the conscious like,
oh I can't,
I'm going to make this dis
this conscious decision. Right.
Which is the last part of your
brain to develop by the way.
And it's like a conscious decision
making be the front frontal lobe cortex.
You know,
something like this.
And it happens and it fully
develops around age 25 by the way.
So if you're (242) 032-0220 one and
all, and so put simply, it's like, okay,
my actions not how do they
affect the future, you know,
it's all in one way or another.
It's going to be kind of surrounded on
that little premise, small little bro.
So otherwise you're just
going not straight auto mode.
However your however you feel that's
going to influence, not totally control,
but that's the thing that's going
to influence your behaviors.
So Times of stress, your frontal
cortex start to shut down a little bit.
Hunger shut down a little bit.
Uh,
hormonal situations for guys and girls.
Oh, so you lose your temper more.
That's where hangry comes from.
Hangry is one of them, you know,
and it's like all these things,
loss of empathy and loss of like all this
stuff where your decisions just aren't
that dope. Yeah. And so,
and when I say hormonal,
like that's why you get roid
rage. You know? Cause like guys,
if they're on steroids,
that's their hormones are up.
Or girls pms scene. It's
like a real, you know,
premenstrual syndrome. It's like
their hormones are all, so her,
one time my wife started
when she was pregnant,
she started crying during
an 18 and t commercial,
Macula Jack Mood.
I
was like, oh my God, what's wrong with
her? Some of those are kind of sad.
Emotional nonetheless, or why were
you crying during Hawaii? Five O man.
Oh, telling me they're training.
They're trying to make it deep man,
that show you're watching them
nod anyway, nonetheless. Um,
it's back to losing your temper and stuff.
It is a week thing.
So it's kind of obvious,
especially from the outside to see
that look, you're losing your temper.
It's not cool.
And a lot of people,
they think it's cool because it
feels good when you're a little kid,
you respect it cause you see
someone lose their temper.
It's like turning into superman. Right? I
mean he's feared, but right. You're
not feared by you look stupid.
That's the message conveyed to your kiss.
Yeah. Losing your temper is stupid. Yeah.
And Amen.
Some people there that you could tell,
they say that stuff with a
little bit of pride, you know,
it's just me and my temper quarterback
is going to get me in trouble.
And they're all like, yeah,
you don't proud. I'm a hot
head man. That's like, oh me,
that should be the guy. I wish I
didn't. That should be. If you say, Hey,
I just have a temper, that should
be the equivalent of you saying,
I don't know how to read. It should
be that, hey, nothing wrong with it.
You can get past it and
you know, whatever. I'm not
going to judge you for it,
but it's not good.
It's not a good state to be in boot.
He's someone who can't
control your temper.
Just like it's not a good state to be
in as a grown adult to not know how to
read no judgment,
but you solve that problem.
That's a B.
If you're having like if your kids have
a temper and they're easy to anger,
it's because chances are,
I dunno everybody of course,
but chances are they
got it from the parents.
Keep in mind you're one of those parents.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that you have a temper.
I'm not saying you don't,
but I am saying, sure kids have a
temporary, your wife as a temporary,
you got it.
Really honestly evaluate,
do I have a temper and
understand that cause the kids,
they're just these little seeds of
beings who were like, hey, how do I act?
I don't know how to act all act out. You
know, just how I feel. I'm going to cry.
This is my default.
I'm just going to cry when something's,
so you're saying the parents have a
temper and show that and act that way the
kids will learn it from you're
going to learn it. So there is some,
there is something like genetic though I,
well maybe I guess it could,
we don't know if it's genetic or not
but there are some where you know the
father has a bad temper and then
the kid has a bad temper. Yeah.
But there's no temper gene.
So what it is is there's a genetic
situation for sure that you're more apt to
not be able to control certain parts
of or not not be able to control but
control less.
You know,
certain parts of your brain or chemistry
is going to make you lean towards
certain types of behavior, like impulsive
behavior or something like that.
There is for sure. But
again, and when you're a kid,
you're just looking for how do I
act? I don't know. I'm growing up.
I don't even know how to act.
So the first thing you're going to look
at is the people might be authority
figures in front of you,
the parents,
if the parents aren't there, who
are they looking to? I don't know.
The guy next door, the guy
on TV, the guy up the street,
the guy in the music video,
whoever. I don't know. Whoever,
whoever's doing better than me.
That's it.
So if you're the parent and you're
losing your temper all the time,
kids going to lose their temper.
Yeah.
That's how what they're going to
learn that act so point there is
if you lose your temper or if
your kids are losing your temper,
you start with yourself
because you know the game
you're looking at and
there's certain things.
It's real easy to see when someone else
does it. Yeah. Most things. But yeah,
it's really, yeah. You simply don't see,
it sounds like this guy here
that asks this question,
he's saying his wife loses his temper and
that could be where the kid is getting
the, the modeling from. Right?
Right. And he's saying he doesn't.
Now is there a chance that he
does to probably, I guess so.
But it sounds like he's pretty
together and he's saying, look,
I just need to get them to
calm down. Right. So yeah,
in this situation I'd say it's probably
the wife who is losing her temper and
then the kid is imitating or modeling
and then we have this scenario happening.
So what we need to do is explain to
everyone in the family that it's not good.
We're not losing our tempers anymore.
The, yeah. And the reason I say it too is,
again,
I'm not saying he does lose his temper,
but I am saying that it is a possibility
that because if let's say mean you are
husband and wife and
I thought we're just broken
kid, me and my wife. Okay.
If she loses the temper,
her temper and I'm taking
the direct approach,
right? Yeah. Which I understand
your lounge evermore. No,
I'm going to lose my temper back.
I'm going to go fire.
I'm going to fight fire with
fire. You raise your voice.
I'm gonna raise my voice.
The kids over there in the corner.
How do I act dope?
That's how I act right there.
That's a possibility and
kids will become antisocial.
That's the thing goes on.
It's one of the things,
one of the many things anti social,
I told you about that book called
Mind Games. Small little book.
Forget the author like pretty clearly
and concisely laid out if you have anger
issues like what? Up with that to
insecurities changed my whole life.
Low self esteem. Next question. Next.
Unless you want to go on.
No, you sure? Next question.
Jocko.
Willink tech tactics to flank slash shift
a ferocious analyzer from paralysis to
go.
Meaning what?
Somebody who overthinks things hesitated.
The landing and planning
and planning and planning.
While there's a couple of things here.
If the person is above you or
below you in the chain of command,
so if they're below you in the
chain of command, you, you know,
you explained to them, you say,
look, we don't need perfection.
We're not going to have a
hundred percent solution.
We don't have 100% of the information.
That's a good enough solution.
We need to move forward. Let's execute.
Um, and you know what? I'll take her
just things go wrong. Don't worry about
it. I'll take responsibility for it.
I'm not going to blame you,
which is what you're gonna
do anyways as a good leader.
So that's what you're gonna do for
their below you in the chain of command.
If they're above you in the
chain of command, guess what?
Same thing you're going to tell him.
Say the same thing. Like, Hey boss,
we don't need perfection
here. Look, Boston,
we're not going to get all
the information we need.
We're not going to get 100% solution.
We've got a 90% solution
and let's go for it.
And if things do go wrong, you can
blame me. I don't care. So boom,
the whether they're above you or
below you, the chain of command,
you might change your tact or your
verbiage a little bit, but it's the same,
same overall concept.
You got to get them to understand
that we don't need perfection,
we need to move forward.
And the other thing is you
explain the cost of not moving,
the cost of staying still,
the cost of being reactive instead of
proactive in basically the cost of not
being aggressive. Cause that's what we're
talking about is a lack of aggression.
And so what does that look like?
What you explained to them
that the longer we sit,
the better position the enemy gets into.
The longer we wait,
the less we know about
what is actually happening.
Think about that one.
The more you sit here and you're planning,
the less we know what's going on
out there. The things are happening,
they're changing, they're
evolving, the enemy's maneuvering.
There's developments on the battlefield
or in the marketplace and you don't even
know cause you're sitting in the
planning space. The longer we wait,
the less time we have to recover
if something does go wrong.
So if we sit here and plan for 47 days
and on the 40th day we sat down and we
start to execute,
something goes wrong.
Well we're not going to make the 50
day mark cause we spent all that time
planning.
So the longer that you're sitting around,
the last time you have to
recover and adapt and adjust.
And the longer that you wait
while you're doing planning,
the less relevant your
plan actually becomes.
So that's what you need
to make people understand.
And then there's people that
are just habitual and chronic,
ferocious analyzers and those
are the people you got to watch.
But you got to continually just get
through their head that the more we sit,
the more the enemy maneuvers.
And if we let them maneuver on us anymore,
we're going to get killed. That's
it. Pretty easy. Well, it's not easy.
It's a simple concept.
It's hard to get people out of their own
heads just like this is like everything
else.
It's hard for the ferocious analyzer to
recognize themselves as that they think
they're doing a good job.
They think they're,
they think they're actually being
thorough. And you're a wild man.
You're a cowboy. Are you
crazy? No, I'm not crazy.
I remember one time when my first
deployment to Iraq, they said, Hey John,
this is after I'd been there for a
while. And they wanted, for some reason,
they wanted to know the
minimum requirements for us
to go out on an operation.
And I said,
I just need a vicinity of the target
and of radio frequency to talk to the
local, uh, conventional units
there. And they were like, well,
don't you need air support? Don't
you do this? And I was, I was like,
all these other things. I was like, no,
we'll figure it out. Just send us. Yeah,
we'll go. And there was other things
that we would do as we move to a target.
We align things up and
weed, but we, we'd be good.
But sometimes people wanted to plan out
every last detail and that doesn't work.
The details are not
going to stay the same.
The things that you're planning
on are going to change.
So don't sit there and plan every last
detail cause not going to help you. Man,
that's actually a pretty good point.
I never even thought about how you say
if you spend too much time planning,
you know, and then you jump in the
game, I'll late. It's like Dang,
you have no time to make any adjustment.
Can react better, go perfect. Cause he's,
that's all he gets a one shot
you got at it and guess what?
It's not going to go perfect
because things don't go perfect. Eh,
things are not going to go perfect.
Not going to happen.
Those sorts of things
is flawless execution.
Dave Burke just wrote an article
that was on business insider.
That's what it was like.
Flawless execution doesn't
happen. Uh, the, you know,
he was a top gun senior instructor
for three years. He, he,
he knows about flying and he knows how
hard they worked to towards flawless
execution, but it didn't exist.
The flawless execution was,
was analyzing their mistakes,
seeing what they can improve upon.
That was flawless execution for them.
It wasn't the actual act of
flawless execution. They, you know,
what they had for all this debriefing,
flawless analization of
what they did wrong. Yeah.
But it wasn't gonna be perfect ops and it
knows no such thing. It doesn't happen.
So if you're sitting in planning
that trying to make that happen,
it's not gonna work for you.
It's don't do it. Just jump.
Go.
Next question Jocko.
Got a question. He actually
wrote that. He did. Yeah.
He's fully gain kind of question.
How would you do with a team member who
tries to take all the responsibility but
cannot do as good a job as others?
I don't know if it's sincere helpfulness
or desire of power and these are for
power.
Who see,
there's a little twist on that one level
twists that puts a lot on that question
right there.
And so you've got a guy that's,
I'm trying to take all this responsibility
for everything and not really as good
as he should be to be in that position,
but trying to take responsibility.
And yet the person
that's got the question,
he doesn't know if it's sincere,
trying to just help out the
team or a desire for power.
So is it helpfulness or is
it their quest for power?
Where they coming from? How do we
figure that out? Well, for one thing,
if someone is truly
trying to help the team,
they will have an open mind to support
and suggestion and help from other
people.
They'll be open to that because they're
just trying to do the best for the team.
If they're trying to
take or maintain power,
which as we know is driven by ego,
very don't want help and they don't
want suggestions from people either.
They're just gonna do it my
way. I got this. No, it's mine.
So that's the difference.
So there's going to be two different
ways I'm going to handle this situation.
So for a person that's actually trying
to help and trying to do a good job,
I'm going to bolster him up. I love it.
The fact that they have some shortfalls,
that's okay. You want me to do,
I'm going to give him some support.
I'm going to put some people on their
team that can help cover some of those
shortfalls.
I'm going to try and set them up to win
and learn and be educated while they are
winning
and if they're humble,
which I'm assuming that they are because
they have this attitude that they're
trying to help out everyone.
Then while I'm doing this whole process,
of course I'm coaching them
and I'm mentoring them and
giving them suggestions,
am turning to someone that can
do a good job in that situation.
So that's pretty easy.
You got someone that wants to take
ownership and responsibility and they're
doing it for the right reasons. Boom,
let's help them out. What support them.
Let's get them training. Let's get them
knowledge and let's get them up to speed.
We got an upcoming leader.
I dig it.
If it's an ego driven person and
they are maneuvering for the power,
okay,
well then what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to let them get humbled by the
experience because remember it stated
that they're not as good as they could be
at this job.
They're not particularly good at what
they're trying to take control over,
so that's fine.
I'm going to let them get humbled by it.
Now I'm going to assess the risks.
I'm going to make sure that no one's
going to get hurt or no one's going to get
killed,
or we're not going to fail a mission or
in the business world makes sure they're
not going to lose millions of dollars
and we're not going to suffer coming to
some kind of a strategic setback,
but I am going to let them fail a little
bit and let them see that they're not
as good as they think they are. I'm
going to let them learn about humility,
right? I'm going to let them learn
about humility. Now, if they learn,
if they are humbled by that and they
realize that they're not as good as they
realize that they're not ready to control
everything and they realize that they
need help. If they learn from it
and they don't just cast blame,
then they'll become a much better leader.
You will actually help them
by letting them get humbled.
If they just get done
and they just cast blame,
then we see them fail and now we
have legitimate reason to say,
look, I can't put you in
charge. You just failed.
I can't allow this to happen again.
So that's how I would basically
handle that situation.
Now of course there's all
different kinds of gradations of,
of those realities and the answer will
be somewhat scaled as well. Right?
So you're, that's what you're,
do you scale the answer?
Maybe you give this person
a little bit of help,
but you're gonna to let them
stumble a little bit. You know,
maybe you're not going to
give me any help at all.
You're going to fall flat on their face.
Maybe you're going to
bolster him up a lot,
but you're still going to talk
to them and say, hey listen,
you need to step back and get more in the
weeds on some of the lower level stuff
cause you're not ready to manage
this yet. You know? So it's
cool.
But that's my basic overall concept
of where I would be going with that.
Do you find that
like even with the expression,
extreme ownership or in this
case all of the responsibility,
do you find that
people get confused but you know, yeah,
like people who will kind of get confused,
you know how you say, okay
take responsibility. Cause
it seems like anyway,
from what I told think,
I totally understand what
extreme ownership is. Eric,
I told understand, oh I liked it.
I like we were coming from on high.
You take responsibility for
the mistakes and the solution.
Yes. Right. That is a dream. Ownership.
So, and then, but then from what I heard,
like sometimes when people
ask questions it'll kind of,
this one's kind of ambiguous,
but sometimes people will ask it,
ask a question or make a statement,
comment,
whatever in terms of take
responsibility or take ownership of like
not have the problems or the solutions.
But, but like before the mission,
like this is my, this is,
you can overstep, you can be,
you can use too much extreme ownership.
You can say, Hey, this is echo,
this is my mission. I'll you how to do it.
Push it from, you know, input from you.
That's all me. Yeah. And by the way, I'm
taking all the credit to when we get back,
which is actually equally wrong,
right? I should do is say, hey,
I will echo, I'm in charge
of this, but hey man,
I want you to come up with a good plan.
I think you've got a great insight.
I think you know the
terrain better than me.
Can you come up with a good plan
and then we'll get backwards.
If it's a successful mission, I'm like,
hey guys, everyone, look what acra did.
And I, I tell the commanding officer
echo ran this great operation.
I think he's ready to step up in
leadership. He really did a super job.
If it fails, what am I doing? The
pointing the finger. Adecco. No,
I'm coming back and said, hey
boss, here's the mission. Failure.
These are the mistakes I made.
Here's what I did wrong.
Here's what I'm gonna fix next time.
That's real simple. So would you say,
in a nutshell,
extreme ownership applies to problems
and the solutions to those problems and
that's all? No, it applies to
everything. It applies to everything.
Because even when I say, Hey, echo, I
want you to come up with a plan for this.
You come back and brief me with a plan.
I still take ownership of the plan.
It's your plan. But I go through it and
say, okay, this looks like a good move.
Hey Echo,
I'm looking at this right here.
I don't know if this is the best way
to execute this. Here's the issue.
So I'm not taking ownership of it,
that I'm pulling it away from you,
but I'm definitely going
to make sure we win. I,
that's the thing that drives me crazy
sometimes with leaders is they don't
realize it, but they're making excuses
because they'll say, oh, you know, I let,
I let me decentralized command. So
I, I can't control everything. No,
actually you are
responsible for everything.
And if I got three teams out there and
you're one of the team leaders and I come
to you and say, Hey, echo, here's
the plan. I want you to execute.
I still have to look at the plan.
I still have to make sure that
I agree with what you're doing.
I have to make sure you're not doing
something that doesn't make sense. Right.
So I, yes, I do have ownership
of the plan. Yeah, absolutely.
Like it's your family member or
something. Yeah. That plan is like,
I love it. Like a sun kind of the plan
is the plan. You came up with a plan,
you created it. It's my grandkid. Yeah.
Yeah. Right. So you're, it's yours.
But I'm still going to take responsibility
and ownership. But where people,
it's when your ego starts flaring
up and I started saying, no,
this is my plan and we're gonna do it my
way. That's where we have issues. Yeah.
But yeah,
the ownership doesn't stop and it just
doesn't stop when you're in a leadership
position. It doesn't stop on everything
up and down the chain of command.
It's hard to do. It's hard
on your ego for sure. Yeah.
Cause it kind of seems in a way countering
too, I guess if you understand though,
they'll all the little
subtle dynamics of it.
Cause you know how like if the plan fails,
boom,
that's when the extreme ownership
is really going to show its head.
If it's a super successful,
flawless plan, it does it.
It's more covert because
it's more internal because
you got to give the credit
for sure. Everyone else, everyone
will will sit there and go,
oh Jockos you know he's, he's giving
the credit to echo for the operation.
We won't show up as
extreme ownership for sure.
It'll be harder to see
and people will say, Dang,
people know that I was
in charge right then.
Don't want me over all the guys so I'm
still going to get some credit. Right. It,
it's more covert, but it's way more covert
and it's matter. It's better. That's,
that's the hard thing. That's what's
so hard for people to realize.
They want so bad to raise their hand
and say, yes, it was me. It was my,
it was my operation. But it doesn't
help you. It doesn't help you.
It feels good for like a half a second
and then you realize you just deflated
yourself.
Is that kind of like when you make a
donation to charity but you want like
everyone to know that you did
it. It's kind of like that. Yeah,
I guess it's similar to
that similar concept, right?
Like in a weird kind of profound way.
That's the question.
I guess we'll just move
on to next question.
How just the profoundness of your last
day to think on a certain level it's the
same thing because you know you
did something good, you know,
or you are something good or whatever.
But it's like saying I'm,
I'm the most humble guy in the world.
You know, I'm just here, down to here.
And here's the other thing about this.
When I give you the credit for success,
not only do I Wayne covertly in
that you look at me and go, man,
he gave me a couple
corrections that were critical.
There's operation and he's
not even saying anything.
So you have even more respect from me,
which means you're going to work harder
for me in the future and you're going to
do even more and we're
going to look even better.
So I am going to ultimately win.
Yeah.
Because my team is going to be kicking
so much ass all over the globe and people
are saying, wow, you know this, these
guys were just winning everywhere.
They go and, and, and so
it's very, very positive.
Whereas if I took that credit from you
on that first operation and I took it
from you, how are you working on that
next one? Not as hard, not as hard.
You know, maybe guy, maybe you're a
great guy, but you're just a great guy,
but you're still not going
to go that extra little edge.
You're not going to do it cause you're
not going to get credit and you're not
going to do because you don't care that
much about making me look good as you
would if I was taking care of you.
There's nothing better than having
guys that you're taken care of.
They know you're taking care of them and
they're going to do anything for you.
Like they're going to do
anything you, you, you know,
and you'll do anything for
them. It's a mutual thing.
It's real. It's a real thing.
Yeah.
It's like the gift that keeps on getting
rid of it is, is a powerful tool.
You know, that's what the book's been
so popular and it's, and, and it's,
it's why the book has been
so popular because when you,
when you break it down and
people see what it does,
they realize how powerful it is.
And it's, and it's also, you know,
another reason that the book is so popular
is because we put it in a very clear
way and it's easier to understand.
It doesn't make it easier to execute,
but it makes it easier to understand
for sure. Yeah. It's crazy to,
oh and someone said, I forget it might
have been someone at the muster, I dunno.
Could, could have very little bit
on Twitter. I don't know. But oh,
someone was saying how it's so interesting
how they started to realize that it
applies to their relationship with their
husband or wife. Oh for sure. Like that.
And I always kind of look at all this
stuff is primarily that, you know,
cause I mean who do it, especially
now, who do I work with you? Oh,
I don't have to, like, I don't go through
these extreme ownership struggles,
Pluto with you. So it's more, you know,
so to me everything up just applies to
like your relationship with your life,
whatever, you know. So and it all
translates all of it. It does. Yeah.
And when you take ownership of stuff,
it's when you take ownership of stuff,
then you can control the outcome. Yeah.
It's crazy. When you don't own it,
you don't get anywhere. Yeah.
And that, that um, you know,
you have a, I dunno,
disagreement, argument, any,
any ripples in the water where the
instinct is to point fingers, you know.
But when you,
even though one other person is really
in the grand scheme of things here,
both to blame,
I know that,
but they do have their huge role in the
issue and the problem don't do that.
Don't even pay attention to that.
All you've got to do is shine the light
on your own things and say, don't, I mean,
and how you say, don't be, don't
be hard on yourself. You know,
like that kind of like the kind, I
suck, I suck. It's not that it's no,
it's like this is what I can do.
Exactly. Right. So what's interesting is,
and you said it from the beginning,
but it is interesting to just watch
it play out. So far it's almost fun,
but it's more just real interesting where
when you do it and you just keep doing
it, you always do it. That's
thing consistently do it.
You just watch how the other person just
changes and just becomes kind of the
same thing.
And before you know it,
like the ripples in the water are pretty
much gone. Yeah. And what's you need,
someone in the team has
got to start doing it.
That's one of the hardest things.
Yeah. Occasionally we'll work with
a company where everyone's like,
oh yeah, extreme ownership.
No one is actually doing it when
no one is actually doing it.
And all they're saying is like,
I wish that guy,
he had extreme ownership and that guy
should have extreme ownership and I don't
see anyone else taking
that ownership and hey,
I haven't seen anyone else taking
ownership and therefore how can I take
ownership?
You know,
we send out when we work with a company
will send out surveys, you know,
pre class surveys and in post, because
we'll, we'll do a number of sessions.
So we'll send out to the leadership team
that we're working with, how's it going?
And we'll, we'll send out a week later,
two weeks later, three weeks later,
four weeks later.
And sometimes when you get a team
where no one is taking ownership and,
and literally you'll hear people say,
well, the boss isn't taking ownership.
So how can I take ownership if the
boss hasn't even taken ownership?
They don't realize that when
your boss isn't taking ownership,
it is an opportunity for you to take
ownership and to excel and to gain respect
than trust and power and power,
which is a good thing because you're
doing things for the good of the team.
So you want to have power, right?
I want to have power when I'm,
when I'm a team leader,
I absolutely want to have power.
And the reason I want to have power so
I can distribute it properly amongst my
team and I can utilize it.
So we can be successful in our mission.
So when you have your CEO
isn't taking ownership,
awesome, I'm going to take
ownership. And when the rest,
if the CEO is truly not
taking ownership and I do,
everyone else looks at me and they
start to, I elevate my position,
that CEO becomes irrelevant because all
he's doing is sitting around pointing
fingers. I'm taking ownership
of things and solving them.
I'm actually going to end up
in a superior position. Now,
I might not get promoted the CEO
today or tomorrow or in two years.
But when this information gets back to
the board or to the directors or whoever,
they realize that there's one person
that's mutually respected by everybody.
And that's Hugh. Because you took
ownership and when you take ownership,
you solve problems and when
you solve problems you win.
But somebody has got to start it.
And it's hard sometimes in some
situations you get the, the,
what's the word they use, like
the caustic environment. Toxic,
the toxic environment
where everyone's just so,
so defensive about everything
and it's difficult.
Those are the difficult situations to,
to work with Bw.
And all it takes is the
transition of one human,
one person in that team to
step up and say, you know what?
This stuff that's going wrong is my fault.
Ceos don't worry about him.
He's got enough problems.
He's got to deal with the,
he's got a deal with the
shareholders meeting. We don't,
we need to protect him.
You know what?
This is my fault that this happened and
here's what we're going to do to fix it.
Here's what I'm going to do.
And that just changes the attitudes.
And of course you're going to have
two or three people in that defensive,
toxic environment that are looking at him
go, yeah, that's right. It is your fault.
And you know what you say to that. Yeah,
you're right. It is. It is my fault.
And here's what we're do. Fix it.
Here's how I'm going to move forward.
Here's what we're going to do to change.
But it's hard to be that person to take
that first step and then you got to keep
that going, you know? But
again, man, after a little bit,
you see the guy next to you, you started
to do it, then the guy next door,
it's an extreme ownership,
the book it's pointed out,
but it's not super crystal clear that
when I was taking blame for the blue on
blue, that happened. Everyone
else was too. You know,
those guys were saying, Hey,
it was my fault. I did this.
It was my fault. I did this.
And that was cause that was,
that wasn't the first time these guys
had seen or heard ownership. You know,
when we were going through training and
something was screwed up, I'd be like,
Hey, this is my fault. Just wanted to end.
So everyone had that really good attitude.
Yeah. So, and that happens in a company.
So what you're saying it does, that's
one of the best things about this idea,
this principle of extreme ownership
is it spreads throughout the company.
And will you get people on the team
that will not take ownership of things?
Yes,
of course you will.
You will get that person and eventually
they will either leave or you will fire
them. One on one of the two things will
happen because when you have a person,
when you've got the whole team
is going, no, it's my fault.
And eventually everyone's, Oh you, oh
you, that's not your responsibility. Cool.
I'll take that. Oh, Echo, you can't handle
that. Cool. That's not your fault. Okay,
then I'll, I'll take it and fix it.
Oh, Echo, you can't handle that either.
It's not your fault. Okay, I'll
take that and fix it. Eventually.
You don't have a job anymore,
so if you want it,
don't want to take ownership
of things including problems.
I will take ownership of all of them and
all eventually take your job and your
world and there'll be mine.
It gets phased, right?
That's phase you write out
like you weren't even there.
That's what's going to happen.
So yes, it's a powerful,
powerful tool.
And then the other thing is you see like
you see politicians do it all the time.
They don't take ownership when they
make a mistake. And when they do,
it's sort of this lip service
of a, you know, it was my fault.
It was my fault that this happened, but
right, right. He bought blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah and tie and
all anyone hears is blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Big Ones. As soon as you say, but,
and then you make a bunch of excuses,
that's all anybody hears. Yeah.
And there's just, it's so weak.
It's so weak to do that. And
it sounds when, like you said,
when you get used to hearing it,
when you get used to hearing
people take ownership of things,
when somebody does it,
it sounds like Satan is
screaming out of their mouth and,
and just horrible. It
sounds awful. It's like a,
it's like a coffin if
you just sickness. Right. That's
what it is. It stands up for sure.
When we are at the muster,
it's like I was talking about how when
you start taking ownership of things,
when you start having this attitude,
when,
when you feel yourself about to a
mistake and blame on someone else,
like you feel like you're gonna throw
up in your mouth, it keeps like your,
it's like you,
it's like vomit is coming out of your
mouth and then you drove it back down.
Cause you don't want to let that puke out
onto the floor and let everyone see it.
It's not allowed. That's all it is. When
you blame, everyone else has all it is,
it happens all the time.
And it's so, it's, it's the,
it's like the other thing
I talk about with, with um,
stepping back and,
and how you step back off the line
and how much visibility you have.
As soon as you step back
off the firing line,
as soon as you just elevate yourself
six inches above what's happening,
it's the same thing when you start to
take ownership. It's like the change.
It's just this little change,
but it just completely changes the dynamic
of what is going on in your business
and in your life, in your life.
Because it's the same thing in life.
When people are blaming everyone else,
they're blaming the market and they're
blaming their parents and they're blaming
the,
the debt that they built up and
they're blaming the car that broke.
They're blaming everything else
that's going on and when you,
when all you and everything,
when nothing is your fault,
what are you going to fix the answers.
You're not going to fix anything.
Whereas if you go,
okay,
these are some mistakes that I made and
here's what I'm going to do to fix them,
that's that paradigm change and that's
where you start getting on the right path.
Oh,
the muster your line at the muster.
I included it in the video.
Favorite line, I think it says,
sure,
I'll take the blame and I don't care.
I have a mission to accomplish and
I got to get the problem solved.
That's what it was. Yeah, it's in the
video. The best part of my opinion.
I will take the blame and I don't care.
I don't care.
Bring it. Bring it Jocko.
We've got time for one more.
Yes.
I think we do.
Jocko on the Joe Rogan experience
Everlast from house of Payne was on mls,
was explaining how he wasn't in shape
and Joe played the good video for every
last said it is inspiring
but it didn't always work.
And the example he gave was a sick
daughter who had lung disease that the
doctors can't explain. I wondered
the same thing. How's the sick child?
Good
yours.
I saw that episode as well and
it's definitely a hard question.
And actually to quote,
okay,
a song, a great song by Everlast and I,
I haven't walked a mile in his shoes
and I've been extremely lucky and and
blessed with the
health of my family,
my wife and my children.
And I am so,
so thankful for that.
But
I have been around disease
and I have been around death
and of course
to say there is something good about
death and disease is impossible to do,
to to hell with disease,
to hell with cancer and als and heart
disease and all the rest of them,
to hell with them all
and death
to hell with death.
I have nothing good to say
about disease or death.
Curse them both,
but,
but then what
is that where I'm supposed to focus?
Am I to latch on to death and disease
and ride with them down to the depths of
despair?
I say,
no,
no.
I will not ride with them.
I will not go down there evil path
instead because I cannot find good
in their vile darkness,
the vile darkness of disease and of Def,
I will not feed their fire.
I won't feed their egos.
Instead
coming to look elsewhere,
I will look to life and light and
I will find good in those places
I find good in every moment I get,
I'll find good in every
breath I'll find good.
Making memories and holding them dear.
I'll find good in knowing
that I will learn from
this horrible experience
that everything that I'm going through,
all the pain and suffering and darkness,
it'll make the light
brighter
and stronger and more powerful,
more powerful than disease
and more powerful than death.
Yeah.
So
cry
and scream
in,
shake your fist at the sky and curse
death and curse disease and shout to the
world that life isn't fair
then.
That this is not deserved.
Not For me, not from my child,
not from my friend, my
spouse, my brother, my sister,
not for anyone.
And then book up
and breathe
in all that darkness and all that evil.
Let it all go.
Peyton,
when it creeps back again,
let it go again.
Let it go.
Yeah,
look forward
toward the light,
toward life,
toward the future
and of the past.
Let the memories,
the sacred memories.
Yeah.
Let those flourish and grow
and expunge the darkness from your world
and replace it all
with good.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
The rough one. Yeah, I think
probably that. Okay. It's like, I think
that like, that outlook
on it is, is important.
Cause that's not just easy to do, you
know, especially men and me probably,
I've been lucky,
my daughter had a staph infection in
her lymph nodes in the hospital for like
week. We can after them like that.
And, and you have the viewpoint,
you're lucky that that happened.
You know,
when you go to a children's ward and you
see kids that are just suffering from
horrible diseases, it's awful. You
feel lucky exactly. As you should,
you know, hey, we're lucky
to have this. Yeah. And at,
in that moment when we were in
the hospital, I'm like, you know,
like you're scared. You're like
sad, scared for them. You know,
it's just,
but I think that just even hearing that,
it's like, it's Kinda like,
it does help, you know? Yeah.
And it's one of the things that,
you know, when, uh, when, uh,
you know, when you talk about the
reaction you have and you know,
the fact that it's okay to like
scream and shake your fist at the sky,
that's okay for that. And then I'm saying,
you know that you've got to let it go.
But at the same time,
everyone's got to realize that like
you let it go, it's coming back,
it's coming back and it'll sneak up on
you again and then you kind of do it
again. You know, you got to, you got to
go through that. You've got to scream and,
and
curse the evil that it is,
and then you got to let it go again and
you're going to go through that cycle
over and over again.
But what you can't do is you
can't not go through the cycle.
You can't just get trapped in the
screaming and the suffering and the pain.
You can't get trapped there. And it's
really hard. And I noticed that, you know,
when I had,
when I had my friends get killed overseas,
I realized, you know, when we'd be home
and like everything would be normal.
Like maybe it would be out having some
beers with the boys or we'd be doing
something and all of a sudden, like you
just get hit with this wave of sadness.
And it would kind of just,
almost instantly I'd be like breaking
down would be that could be like ready to
cry or crying and then three
minutes later I'm like out of it.
You know?
I just had to get rid of it.
I just had to expunge that sadness and,
but what you can't do is you just
can't get caught in those cycles.
And I think that's what happens to people.
And again,
I haven't walked a mile in those shoes,
but what I have seen is
I know that it's hard.
I know that it's heartbreaking,
but you can't let it break everything.
You have to try and hold it together.
Yeah.
It's like part of the like going through,
I know this little low level,
I guess I understand
it's like a low level,
but part of like the feeling that you
get is like what do I do? Like I don't,
I feel like he can't do anything. And then
that provides these feelings, you know?
But if you start to, to understand
what it is that you do have to do,
and one of those things is, is
essentially like understand it that yeah,
it's going on.
Don't try to block it or escape,
do some escapists activity or whatever.
Just know and understand that it's
going on. And then on top of that,
on top of it, your job is
to be strong, you know? Yep.
You know, that's, that's another
thing that I've noticed especially,
and it happens with anybody but with
some of my CEO friends that have been in
these horrible situations,
is there Alpha guys that are used to
being in control of everything and used to
being able to control the outcome and
you all of a sudden you can't. Yeah.
You can't control the outcome.
And then what do you do? Well,
it's like we learned from Charlie plum.
It's like we learned from bill reader,
you can't control that thing.
The only thing you can
control is your own attitude,
your own view of what's happening.
And if you're,
if you control your attitude and you
make your attitude the best possible
attitude it can be. That's the
best you're going to do. And again,
I wish there was some,
I don't have some
miracle solution to these situations
and no one does. If we had the miracle,
these problems wouldn't happen.
These horrible things wouldn't happen.
So what can we actually control?
Who will keep control is our own
view of it. Our own assessment,
our own attitude,
and that sounds like a trite word,
but our own attitude of what's happening
and make that as good as we can.
And are there going to be points where
your attitude turns completely dark and
negative? Of course there
are. How can you not?
But don't let it be permanent.
Don't let it be permanent for
the sake of the situation,
for the sake of the person you care about.
They don't want you to live like that.
So don't, and again, there's,
you know it's going to be sick
Sicko core from what I've seen,
it's going to be cyclical in nature.
The way it happens,
the way people deal with these horrible
emotions is they go down and then they
come up and then they go down and they
come up. And, and when they go down,
when your emotions go down and when
you get dragged into the, the, the,
the mindset of loss,
then I think the best thing to do is
just embrace it. Grab it, say yeah.
And she's like I said,
shake your fist at the sky and scream
and then let it out.
Get it out and then pick it back
up and say to yourself, okay,
that was horrible.
That's darkness,
that's evil that I couldn't control.
What can I control and how can I have
the best possible view and what can I
learn from all this that's going to make
me a better person with a better life
to live the best I can in their memories?
No ma'am. And even men and men,
when you're in the situation,
like,
especially with working out where
your daughter is like, you know,
in the hospital or whatever
and you're like, yeah,
I haven't worked out this whole week.
It's like,
who cares about worked out to your
daughter's in the hospital? You don't, Oh,
you didn't make it did you do to like,
you don't care about Jujitsu anymore.
You just care about this one thing, you
know. But again, just like how you said,
it's like, so it's like this big burden
in life because really, you know,
you've done a lot of time.
Your kids are like all you have really,
it feels like, so if you don't
have them who hears about Jujitsu,
who cares about working? I
don't have anything. You know,
there's no reason to even do them.
Rarely.
But aside from the fact is there is more
like to your life and in fact the more
your whole life beside them is for them,
you know, so you gotta you gotta
of you gotta keep that I think.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Yeah. And I think that's always an
important thing to remember is that
if you surrender to all that bad,
evil darkness,
that's the legacy.
That's the example.
That's what you're showing.
As opposed to
showing the legacy and
showing the example of
not giving up,
of moving forward,
of driving on and doing the best you can
with life and with the things that are
good. And again, having the attitude
to control the things you can control
and put them in the best possible light
that you can.
Yeah. And it's a, and it's
a spectrum, you know, I mean
it kind of puts into perspective,
in my opinion,
why you should do the best you
can when things are going good.
Yeah. Cause they're not
always going to go good. Yeah.
That's my opinion anyway.
Speaking of doing the best you can,
hey look, working out, we
know, obvious, obvious workout.
We're good. Hard to, you
know, I mean maybe not every
single day working on heart,
but workup and when you do workout hard,
you might need some supplementation.
I think. I wasn't a supplement guy,
I wasn't before you know this, right?
I might've mentioned it,
everyone knows,
but now I am a supplement guy.
Happy to say,
not the kind of supplement guy who's
like, Hey, take this power gainer. Hey,
what kind of protein powder you take?
But even though I'm not against protein
powder, I don't take in. But nonetheless,
you know what I'm talking about?
Krill oil.
I'm gonna say to my father in law's
name is Ross. I'm sorry for not heating.
All of you is heating,
heating, his just advice.
Can you heat advice or is it just morning?
Okay.
So you can heat warnings and advice.
I should have heated Ross's advice.
My father in law about the Krill oil
eventually chocolate turned me
back onto it or further onto it.
So I'm on it now. I think he'd
be happy literally on it on it.
Dot Collin intended anyway on it is the
company. If you didn't know already,
I get Jocko gets Krill oil from on it
on a.com if you want 10% off all these
supplements, which are what?
Shroom Tech K shroom tech,
good for oxygen uptake is what it is.
So when you're doing these
hardcore metcons Jujitsu,
your body takes up the oxygen
easier, more, more efficiently.
Cordyceps, mushroom, just some science
for you. Right then strong bone.
That helped me. But I had this, um,
and I kind of want it to report this
before but I didn't want to take too much
time and the jury is still kind of
out on it. But so I had this tendon,
itis kind of situation and it's weird.
It wasn't in like a normal place they can,
your elbow was in my deltoid muscle
where it inserts into the humerus bone,
which is your like bone under your bicep.
And it was like tendonitis, tennis,
like in the kind of like I'm not injured,
I'm not out. But I would warm up more.
I got to rub on it and all
this stuff and I'm lifting,
I'm not going to take days off
if I'm not injured. So Brett,
this thing wasn't going to get better.
That's the thing about tendinitis.
Like if you keep lifting hard on it,
it just simply won't go away.
It's the whole reason this tendinitis
cause you're lifting hard on it, you know,
and I'd rather see it's not going away.
I'm just going to have to live
with it or wait for, you know,
the time where I'd done, I don't
have to skip work cuts, whatever,
but I'm on the strong bone. I'm like I
strong bone that's see what up, you know,
do your thing. I'm not saying it
was because of the strong bone,
but nonetheless the tendonitis, it's not
completely gone. I'm be honest with you,
but it's pretty much gone.
I'm warming up normal.
I'm a believer of this John Boom. Thanks
for turning me onto that check Jocko.
Anyway,
go on there.
There's a lot of good stuff for a lot
of good things from supplements and
there's workout stuff on there too.
So I already had weights
and gym membership,
but when you go on there,
you see the stuff that they have.
You're going to get some of that too.
Cause it's not like normal
like kettle bells, you know,
there's all the cool ones and
there's info too on this stuff.
Like I understand that you know,
a lot of people, a lot of us,
we want more info than just Ooh joke.
Who takes it? So I'm going to take it.
Some of us that are like that anyway,
we need more info so
there's info on the website.
Be careful.
You can get stuck on there because it's
real interesting and in depth by the way,
so just be careful with that.
You know on it.com/jocko
I recommend the Krill oil.
Big Time to me, if you're not on the
Krill oil, you're, you're behind.
You're like a good one to two
steps behind, like steps, steps,
not like a half step,
like if you're behind.
If I had a twin brother,
which I do,
you give us a five year period,
two year period, I'm on Krill oil.
He's not on Krill oil. We do the same
exact workout program, same lifestyle.
I'm way ahead of him. When out of him we
were more functional. This is factual.
I that's it's, this is
my hypothesis. Oh, okay.
It's hypothetic Jadon curler. I
don't, yeah, he's on Krill oil,
but he don't have that same, he doesn't
get after it physically as much as I do.
So this, yeah, it's hard to have that for
a basis of comparison for the Krill oil.
Nonetheless, a good stuff on there. And
the good thing about audit, you can,
I can say this with pretty much with
absolute certainty at this point is that
it's the good one. It's good stuff
because supplements in general,
I don't want to mention any store names,
but you know when you go in the meathead
bodybuilders store a lot of those
supplements or are there whack,
they just have like sparkly like labels
and stuff in their junk on it is not
like that. Um, get 10%
off. If you want 10% off,
go on it.com/jocko that's a good
way to support this podcast as well.
Another Good Way to support my pee.
He knows what's interesting is get
you read your review books on here.
And sometimes, actually a lot of
times when you have the guests,
you actually have their book
and you read their book to them,
which is like a,
that was,
and I think probably talked about this,
but when we had Jody medic,
that was the first time it happened.
Jodi came on and you know,
I had this book and I was like,
okay,
well should I have him read
this or should I read this?
Or I just wasn't quite sure.
And it seemed like the
common sense answer would be,
Jodi read this section of your book,
right?
Or it's kind of like a common sense
answer and then you can talk about it.
And for some reason my gut told me,
don't know Jocko read it.
I read right.
And as soon as we got, you
know, probably, I don't know,
halfway through it Jody said,
you know something like man here and
you read this is like crazy to hear.
And it's true when you hear
someone else read something to you,
it's, it's different.
It's different. Yeah. So,
so that's what I've done every time since,
you know,
when we had colonel reader on
here and he said the same thing.
It's hard when he usually,
you know,
he's like he's saying the most unemotional
way is that when you're reading this
to me it's extremely emotional
for me to hear. Yeah. We can,
you know, but it's, and, and same thing
with, with uh, Captain Plumb, you know,
same thing as well. Yeah. Yeah. So it's,
it's really interesting the way
that works. And it's definitely,
it's unbelievable to have the
author sitting there. Yeah.
And to have my spin. Yeah. Cause
that's what it is. Right? It's my,
it's the way I hear it.
Yeah.
And for them to hear the way I hear it,
they,
it, it hits them from a different
angle. Right. So I think that's,
I think that's where the, the
interesting, powerful part comes from.
Yeah. It is very interesting. And
it's interesting to watch it because,
and you know,
you,
you're a little bit different than a
typical person just reading a book,
you know, so you really get the to
me is what it feels like is like,
that's kind of how the book
is supposed to feel. You know,
like when you read it or whatever. So
you know where the point is like, oh,
I think a lot of people feel
that. So you know, they say,
oh I want to go get this book. But they're
like, oh, what was that book again?
I got to rewind it. So anyway, you don't
have to do that. Just go on our website,
[inaudible] dot com there's
a section on the top books,
boom there they are all
the books by episode
whom you can get them in and when you
buy your books through their support,
the podcast as well. So
boom, double, double edge,
double gravitational hooks. Like no,
it's a two pronged. Yeah. What if,
what if you weren't getting a book? You're
getting like duct tape, anything? Yeah,
so that's thing. Yes there are Amazon
click through situations. So, yeah,
even if before you do shopping, boom,
just click through. We've got banners,
Amazon manners all upon their click there.
But most people they do the books,
you know. But yeah, if you're doing
your shopping as well, do that.
Good software clubs, golf clubs, whatever
you do cameras and some people don't.
Some pretty cool high ticket, high dollar
items. Yeah. Which is very impactful.
And in the low ticket items,
low lower cost items,
you might not think it's a big deal,
but then when a bunch of people do it,
it is a big deal and it's a very, very
helpful yeah. To the podcast. Yup. Good.
With spark [inaudible] boom,
a little bit.
Also good way to support this
podcast is to subscribed.
Seems obvious. I know. But you know,
if you haven't subscribed on iTunes,
Google play,
stitcher.
Okay.
What's the other one that I keep
missing? I don't know. Hey man,
whatever podcast those before
you that I post almost.
It's something about soundcloud.
I gotta look into it.
I don't think that that's the subscribed
podcast situation. I don't know.
They're just audio for, I
don't, I don't know either.
So she didn't even say anything,
but nonetheless,
I look into it if in fact
people are committed to the
side owned cloud situation.
Anyway,
subscribe if you haven't already.
Also youtube if you want or are interested
in the video version of this podcast.
It's been on there since number seven.
I think seven was the first
video episode we are on there,
but they're just audio with
the picture of your head. No,
I can tear hit this button.
Right. It's his face it, but yeah,
if you're interested in that to
video from back then I do kind of,
I'm so bummed out we don't have it.
Yeah.
The closest you have is like a picture
of me trying to low was it hall is the
App Periscope? Periscope, yeah.
Yeah. I remember that one.
We did it go live on periscope.
We tried. No, we did. We did.
Did it live on periscope, Huh? Yeah.
Just try and capture that video. I know.
Nonetheless via video. That's the point
there. If you want to see, you know,
I guess what we look like
if you don't know. I don't
know. I feel like the guests,
that's where the value comes in for,
she'd like to see Ryder Hayden,
the heroes after it. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
That's a good one too. Cause he's like,
uh, like his stories, man. It's fun.
He acts things out a little
bit as he said. Yeah.
But in this real mellow kind of nonchalant
bad ass way, you know, she's real good.
Um, but yeah, youtube, subscribe to
that one if you like. I'm also, yeah,
it's the video version of the podcast.
Yes.
But I will take a little excerpts
and we'll post those as well.
So you can, you know, if you'd like,
if you're in just sharing little
lessons with your friends or coworkers,
whatever, you can do that so you
don't have to share the whole podcast.
I'll put some other stuff on there.
Interesting stuff.
I think we'll think up some other
stuff just in relation to it.
We've been spit balling about some stuff
anyway, if you want to see what that is.
Um, yeah, go on Youtube. It's not
like youtube cost money or does it?
No, it doesn't. It's free
youtube. Red Customer. Yeah. Yeah.
We're not dealing with youtube
red and we're not doing that. No.
And I don't charge for content. Oh No, no,
we're not going to do that. Not Enough.
But I was thinking about getting
youtube, Bro. All right. Yeah,
that's a whole nother thing for
sure. But yeah, youtube subscribe.
You will support that way. That's
cool. Uh, also Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store Taco store.com.
So this,
I keep forgetting everybody's name, but
very clever guy said, hey, this was,
and then I went through and I was
like, Dang, I'm so, but I was like, ah,
it's not a Haiku. The Jocko story.
Yeah. So why don't you change it?
So it's a high coup because
it might, yeah, I guess. Okay,
here we go.
Also
Jocko has a store,
it's called the Jocko
Jocko store.com boom.
There was like cool. Nonetheless, jackals
store.com that's where you can get,
if you want shirts,
rash guards,
hoodies,
some patches,
velcro, regulation size and color.
So I'm some women's stuff on
there. Anyway, the point there is if
you like t shirts you want to represent,
get a shirt, boom, good
support. They're good shirts
too. They're not the free time.
When you put on get after t shirt.
Yeah.
Do you get a little bit? Yeah.
You want to get after it mark.
And actually the eight,
that actually sounds kind of funny,
but when you think about
it's super obvious. So like,
you know how like, I mean
it's a litterer literature thing.
Well there's a literature thing.
It's called something. It's
called something like the
dressing of the warrior.
Yeah. And you'll see it in
movies. They do the movies.
We should have guy
putting his boots on him,
putting his gear on and putting his sword
and picking up a shield that's dawning
his helmet.
They do everyone from knight movies to
gladiator movies to soldier movies in the
modern day. You'll see these scenes.
Well they do it in literature too,
so there's a little something that
there's little reality to that.
Like I'll tell you what used to
get me was flipping down. Sorry,
night vision goggles.
You're wearing them on your helmet and
they flip up when the lights are on,
when you're, you know,
you're getting ready to go.
And then when it's time to go
flipped down your nods. And for me,
I like that was just games.
So game on,
it's so game on when you flip
down those nods. And so when we,
even when I got back
from my last deployment,
I'm working training and we'd go out,
we'd still be on night vision,
we'd go out at night to observe the
troops and run the opposing forces and all
that.
But I get out on the target area and flip
down my nods and I'd let go into full
combat load.
It's just so good.
So I think sometimes you put on a guitar
three shirt you sorta feel or something.
Yeah, I think it was gladiator.
That movie when they're like,
I dunno, it's like the
emperor or something came up.
And then there's like the small act of
defiance from the gladiator guy and then
all the guards behind them,
they'll flip down the thing and boom,
we're ready to go real quick.
I think he's glad eight or probably it
might've been something else. Nonetheless,
he had the modern version of
that right with these like,
and it did happen to me when
the first shirts came in,
the discipline equals
freedom. I was like, oh,
the shirts there and I put it on and
I want it to like go work out in it,
you know? And they make sense.
When you get a new rash guard,
it's like where you get a new key
or something and you're like, oh,
can't wait to go practice it.
My new geek kind of thing when they
were little kids get new shoes that can
write faster. In football, when
we split in Pop Warner football,
we'd get the new shoes for the season.
I can't wait to go to practice.
Practice super hardens.
It sucks do especially as a little kid,
but you just want to, when you get
that, that new stuff nonetheless.
So like I said, chocolate
store.com get yourself a new shirt.
You get the one that says get after it.
Guess what you're going to
really want to do, get after it.
Some other ones on there. Pretty cool I
think, and the good their quality shirts.
That's,
in my opinion,
that's even more important than what
it says on them cause they're wearable.
I can print like,
yeah,
Jack was cool sayings on a junk shirt
you were at one time. You're like,
all right,
you
know me. Be aware of that again,
but it's not very wearable.
I don't look that good in it.
It's not the case with these ones.
These ones look good.
I've had multiple people say it's my
favorite shirt to wear it because I look
good in that. That's kind of a shirt
with the first round of travel mugs.
The silver ones.
Oh yeah.
They were not as high
quality as what we went to.
They said no. They said discipline equals
freedom on him and the silver mugs.
They said discipline equals freedom.
They looked pretty cool,
but we needed higher cost. Higher
Quality. Yeah. Yeah, so it's, yeah,
essentially the same thing and you get
the monkey like cool travel mug is going
to go in the distance that's going
to replace your whole cup cupboard.
It's straight up. It did with me and
I didn't even expect that. But yeah,
30 ounces and it fits in your couple of
doing your car too. What's the black on?
Black? Black on black discipline equals
freedom. No one can see it. Yeah.
You except for you. Well, the
owner. Nah, you can see it.
Here's the good thing about
it. It's black. It's east
seat. Look at it. It's black.
It's not shiny. It's black. Fresh
and shiny. Black and then, yeah.
Then the logo and stuff,
his shiny black.
So people have to look a little
extra hard to see it. Yeah,
but there's a subtlety to it that's
powerful. It's for you. It's for you.
It's looks dope. They call it murdered
out and the car's black with black rims.
Anyway, it looks good and it's
double insulated. Dealt with.
Is that double insulated is, that's what
it's called? Yeah. When, yeah, your ice.
You put ice water in there. You leave
it over night. Next morning still.
You still have ice water. Even if
it's a hot night, even if thought day,
it's amazing. I left my
name, my car. You know,
you go into the grocery store,
you spend a lot of time in negotiation.
No, no. I was coming back from somewhere,
left it in my car with I, it was just ice.
I drink all the water and left it in.
My car came out later that evening.
Boom.
I still in the car today. It's amazing.
It's a miracle. Anyway, those are good.
High Quality, BPA free,
all that stuff. Anyway,
Jaclyn, store.com if you
didn't know already. Also,
good way to support yourself and this
podcast by happenstance is psychological.
A psychological warfare is what it's
called. If you don't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks of Jocko telling
you how to get through your moments
of weakness in the event of you
having a moment of weakness,
getting up early, procrastinating,
even being created.
It's like for everything being creative,
like how can,
how can you get talked out of writer's
block? How can you get talked out of that?
It's weird,
right?
You will be talked out of writer's
block and right into creativity. Yes,
exactly right.
And same thing with workouts anyway for
all the little moments of weakness that
you might have. Don't worry Jack was
there, get it. Psychological warfare,
you can even buy the individual
tracks do let's say your life just no,
but that's not as good of a deal.
But I mean really 99 cents. Yes it
is a good deal. It's a great deal.
Regardless in my opinion. Cause Look Kid,
my whole thing wasn't the wake up early.
It was going from not
working out to where,
you know how it's like okay I've got to
work out today but I'm on the computer,
I'm doing something.
And I'm like this is important to exactly
what you should really focus on my
craft. Right? Yeah, exactly right.
So the workout day becomes
arrest day impromptu, you know,
and that was kind of my thing.
But so there's a track for that,
you know?
So if all I need is really that,
try the Diet thing,
I'm not that weak when it comes to
like the Diet stuff. So you know,
so maybe I don't need it,
but I'm not saying to do that.
I'm saying there's that option. So
he gets the one, it's on iTunes,
it's on Amazon music.
Google play,
Google play pretty much anywhere where
they sell music, MP three online mp3s,
boom. It's on there. It's called the
cycle of people that want to alarm arm
clocks. So people was one an alarm
clock or ringtone. You told him no,
no alarm clock.
If you want to wake up to like
someone telling you to get up that,
then that's someone that's taking Jocko.
Yes,
because people want me to
do something like that, but
I'm like, we already did it.
That's one of the reasons why we did this.
A psychological warfare. Yeah. So you,
yeah. You download that Pacific file
to your phone and then you, yeah,
you'll make it make it to your alarm
clock. Yeah. Yeah. Psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink.
Boom.
You can also get Jocko white tea on Amazon
and people ask if I ever drink energy
drinks and the answer's yes,
but drink Jocko white tea,
that's my energy drink.
Sure.
Don't need any other energy drinks
that actually SAP your energy.
Once they're,
once they're crash hits you talk away to,
that's not going to happen.
You'll be going strong way.
The warrior cured the book.
I wish I had when I was a kid.
That shows kids the path.
You can get that book as well as for
adults that would need to get on the path.
There's another book coming out.
October 20th,
2017 discipline equals freedom field
manual. It's the path that's it.
Extreme ownership of course,
combat leadership from the battlefield
and translated into strategies and
tactics that can be applied in any
leadership situation. Extreme ownership.
Get it and then did it
also do.
You can also get echelon,
front leadership and management consulting
into your company. You got Leif Babin,
you got JP do now.
You got Dave Burke and you got me.
You can contact us@infoatechelonfront.com
of course the muster leadership
conference, but not your
normal conference. It's
not your normal conference,
so don't whatever your of a conference,
because I've spoken at a bunch
of conferences that conference.
It's not that it's different. It's
different. The normal conference,
you're waiting for the break and then
you're going to disappear to your hotel
room for like 45 minutes waiting for
the happy hour, all that other stuff.
That's not, that's not what we're doing
here at the conference. At, at the muster,
the muster starts at eight
o'clock in the morning.
Everyone's there at seven o'clock in
the morning after we get done with PT.
Everyone's there at seven
o'clock in the morning,
including all of us were hanging out.
We, when we start at eight o'clock,
we start at eight o'clock.
Boom. It's go time.
So it's not just your kind
of typical conference thing.
We get after it. Knowledge,
interaction, solving problems.
We go and we go hard. I just peeked out
the microphone. I don't do that normally,
but we go and we'd go hard. Next one
is in August, or sorry, in Austin,
Texas. July 13th and 14th at
the Omni Barton Creek resort,
which only has 300 people.
We're a little over.
We're over halfway sold out right
now. Um, so register quickly.
If you can't make that,
you can come to San Diego September 14th
and 15th for muster at zero zero four
we look forward to seeing you there.
And until we do see you there,
if you want to talk to us,
you can find us drifting about
inside the interwebs on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on Dat facey Bull Ha
Echo is at echocharles and
I am at jockowillink and as
always to the military personnel
deployed all over the world.
Thanks for everything that
you do for us to the police,
firefighters, EMT, first responders.
Thanks for keeping us safe and make sure
you stay safe as well to everyone else
that's listening.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for supporting.
Thank you for spreading the word.
Thank you for getting up early and thanks
for working harder than your enemy.
And as Echo said earlier,
thanks for taking advantage of when times
are good because times will not always
be good.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.